Hello everybody, hello hello!
Oh yeah, I forgot to move stuff around the my desktop!
Okay, there we go.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hope you're feeling better, Mito.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Um...
For...
for context to anybody i woke up this morning i was like oh my gosh my throat hurts so much and i think it was my sinuses have been so bad real talk real talk because even then like an hour ago i was like oh my gosh i can't stop coughing so if i'm if i'm coughing a lot sorry like that uh on stream um Real talk!
My maid cafe is so old and I've had a lot of problems with mold and I think it's trying to send me to the after afterlife.
So hopefully, hopefully, I can move soon.
Hopefully.
Yeah.
It's been really bad So the super mega afterlife.
Yeah The point of no return So yeah, sorry, I feel like I feel like if I'm I feel like recently I've been so like I've don't feel well.
I don't feel well and um, it's that Our girlfriend says hello back me though.
Hi girlfriend
Congratulations on your sister getting an alt.
Do you read Shimiko Blue Archive?
I saw, I woke up, I checked Twitter, and I immediately saw everybody being like, Shimiko, Shimiko, Shimiko, and I was like, what's happening?
And then, and then they were saying that, or I saw like her, what was it, the outfit and everything.
And all I could think of was, oh my gosh, I'm so happy.
happy for Ayami mama.
I'm so happy for Ayami mama.
I know she's she has tried so hard to to push Shimiko and I hope that this is one of the big things that really pushes her out there so yeah I'm happy.
I'm so happy.
This is the one thing I love so much about Ayami mama.
She cares so much about all everything that she draws you know.
Every every person every character so it's something I really really love about yummy mama well I'm drinking hot tea so that hopefully in my maybe I'll maybe my lungs will something because luckily my throat doesn't hurt anymore my cough is all from my chest.
It's nice when it feels personal.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, hmm.
But anyway, welcome back to Silent Hill F.
We just ended on the boss, right?
I just, I just, it was, oh my gosh, what's her name?
Now I'm wanting to say Shimiko.
It's, it's a big word.
Thank you so much for the gifted!
And now I'll thank you earlier for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Sakuko, thank you.
Sakuko.
I was like, I know it ends with a ko.
Everybody's names end with a ko.
Hinako, Sakuko, Rinko, everybody is ko.
Oh yeah, I chose this time.
I'm trying to be more consistent with my schedules.
Whereas I have Wednesday off and Sunday off.
And then Saturday I want to do like an EU friendly stream.
I'm so sorry that today's EU friendly stream is the middle of a game.
So, but hopefully it's still okay.
Lord Kratos, I thank you so much for the time gifted.
Kamakuras, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
But yeah, I want to be more consistent with my schedule.
scheduling.
Where was I going with that?
I don't remember.
But that's okay.
Oh, that's right.
I picked this early time because I was like, oh, I want to play a lot more.
I think we have still so much to get through in the game.
So I was like, I really want to lock in and knock out a good, decent chunk today.
But then I was like, we'll see.
If my cough goes away, end up starting to feel better.
I will play because it's not my throat that's hurting, so it's okay.
It's just hard to breathe a little bit, so.
How can I sleep well at night knowing my cute ghost mid is moldy and dusty?
Where did the dusty come from?
Wait!
You're making stuff up!
where am I
what's our goal wait
uh wait what's the goal wait where are we go oh we're going to Shoe's house which is uh uh Shoe's house where was that because he wants to go to the mountains right he wants to go to the mountains to the mountains so that's why you're green so that mold in my hair yeah exactly press y oh wow okay wait that's so far oh my wow okay okay i was like looking for his little face that's my house okay yeah because what we're trying to do is find a way to escape Ebisu Gaoka,
but probably it's not going to happen.
You know.
Road trip.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
We have to go so far out.
Ah!
I have to go back through.
No.
I have to go back through the fields.
No, please.
No.
Wait.
Eh?
But there's Xs everywhere.
How do I get back over there?
Hmm?
Maybe that's X.
right there in the middle of the screen how do i do oh there maybe this way but it's crossed out do i have but everywhere back to the fields is crossed out too because i went through this house it only looks like it's a one-way moment of appreciation for how gorgeous the map is i know right wait the but the house is one way let's check out this x and see if maybe It's opened up for us.
Whoa!
What is that?
You see that over there?
The big lump of flesh?
Um, what is that?
I'm going the right way, right?
Okay, yeah.
Alright.
What is this?
Um...
Uh...
Why would you say that?
Horror stories are well known for their happy endings, especially Silent Hill.
Especially Silent Hill, especially things created by Japanese creators.
Okay, wait, hold on.
I also have to remember.
Okay, this is how I...
Okay, oh, this is my focus.
Okay, there we go.
There's my medicine.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so we know that this is a bad way.
All right.
Hope you've been practicing your swing.
Good old Shu, but he's been quietly cheering Hinako on from his house while watching her from a telescope way over there.
Yeah, that's our guy.
That's our friend.
Yep.
So maybe whatever was blocking this over here, I don't remember what it was.
Wait, I see a person.
Is that Shu?
Oh, I think it's Shu.
Okay, cool.
So we're just following him.
Oh, and Rinko's there too.
I wish you guys would stop abandoning me.
Hello.
Why are you such a hater?
Isn't that what you would want, Nico, that you don't want him to treat her like a girl?
Right.
Like, wouldn't you want that because then he doesn't see her as a girl?
and then they're not she's not a rival right is that not the way of thinking I don't know I don't understand her with friends like Nico who needs enemies right oh gosh okay okay so yeah now it's opened up why was it closed before I don't remember okay perfect we don't have to the game is so kind it's not I also heard,
or I read somebody in the comments saying that, if you break your weapon, they will spawn another one on the screen.
So that's very nice.
Adding back to Tokyo this year!
Really want to catch some small idol shows, recommendations, where to look for tickets, or groups to look out for.
Thank you for haunting.
Small idols.
It really depends on your taste.
Uh, you can find a show happening every day.
Ah!
Mint is small idle.
What are you saying?
You think they're still in there?
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
This game scares me.
Okay.
What was up here?
Have I gone up there?
I went all the way up there?
I don't remember that.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna sneeze.
Oh no.
Please.
I don't want to sneeze.
Oh, it hurts.
Wait, I want to sneeze.
I don't want to sneeze.
I'm fine.
What is that?
Is that flesh?
It's not moving.
Oh, it is definitely...
fleshy of the fleshy variety.
Just waiting for the jump scares?
Yeah, I'm scared.
Wait, okay.
Let's plan a route, right?
Because everything is blocked off.
So much stuff is blocked off at least.
Where am I supposed to get there?
Like, I'm sure they'll...
Yay!
Can we keep going?
Just ignore her.
Things are getting a little...
Oh, my friends are over there!
They're waiting for me!
Everything is so fleshy.
Everything is getting worse!
Oh, golly.
Um...
Yes?
What's wrong?
Why music?
Hello?
Is it my friends?
Oh gosh.
Why is she so weird?
Also, I just realized something, give me one second after.
One second.
Why is she so weird, though?
Okay, so we're going this way.
One second.
I think I have the brightness up.
I did!
Oh my gosh, I did.
oopsie
and then also that okay oh my gosh i had a bunch of stuff that for something else i was doing oopsie there we go okay i was like wait i was looking at obs seriously i was like why is it so bright hmm space wars space wars wasn't just about fighting evil with laser guns We'd pretend to analyze the enemy by drawing alien sketches.
During PE, we'd say that the class was a training camp for the space army.
I think we played with dolls too.
Right.
I think that's when we were training in first aid in order to assist the injured.
Wow, they got really into the space wars thing.
I walk this path every time I go to Rinkos, but to be honest, to this day, I'm still scared that I might get lost.
I mean, I've been told that I should probably just ask an adult.
for directions if i get lost but then i remember that one time when i walked on the footpath of the rice fields for fun and got smacked by an old farmer all of a sudden the trauma from the experience made me scared of adults back then and even to this day why did he smack her
why is the musical freaky though it's not behind me is it okay no it's just scary for no reason
Uh, sure.
I don't have enough, right?
Oh, I only have one of each, so I'm not going to do that.
It's 500.
Yeah, it's 500 for the Omamori.
And then increased abilities is also 500.
Oh, okay, okay.
Just randomly getting smacked by old farmer.
normal day in japan i suppose okay so yeah see everything's getting more and more red oh my gosh if we go straight what if i feel like maybe it's this path maybe the truck has somehow been moved maybe that one guy moved it or so the big monster one of the most useful life hacks i wish i learned much earlier in life is you can suppress by pressing the roof of your mouth with your tongue.
Yeah, but like, when you guys suppress a sneeze, doesn't your nose get more clogged?
That happens to me.
You see how I sound all sniffly now?
Oh.
Okay, so this way is blocked.
Catch up with Shu and Linko.
I hear one, though.
Oh, I hear it over there.
Okay.
Wait, it hasn't been mine.
Mark just blocked it.
Oh!
A baseball bat!
What's it called?
An ordinary wooden bat.
I would play with this a lot, so I feel right at home.
Oh!
Wait, I got to keep the sickle?
Oh, the sickle's about to break it, it looks like.
I think.
But also...
I think...
I think it probably would be better to get rid of one of the pipes.
I think the sickle was really good though, no?
If I could repair...
I don't...
You get a repair toolkit, right?
Okay, hold on.
Oops.
Trying to remember how to change my weapon.
There we go.
Okay, okay.
Let's try the baseball bat.
I don't like it.
Now is it marked off?
What the heck?
Why isn't it marking it though?
Because like, it can't cross, you know?
Maybe if I get real close and personal.
Okay, there we go.
I'd like to have my map updated, please.
Up to date.
Catch up with them.
Where did they go?
Oh, there's two of them.
Okay.
I need to be careful.
Oh gosh, there's two of them.
Oh, I wish I had a gun!
Well, this one is in the fence, so...
Maybe it's okay.
I wish I could go.
I'll win.
Okay, walk away now.
Thank you.
Oh gosh, this one's...
coming back they're gonna hear me they're gonna hear me attack and both double team me
gosh okay hold on i'm gonna try and time this
oh my god it's so scary i don't like them at all
uh oh wait did they come after me no stinking way
ah there's three of them oh my god God, it's time to go.
It's time to go.
Oh, wait!
We can't run!
I'm so lost.
Wait, I'm lost now.
Wait.
Where am I?
Scary!
Okay, there's apparently an alleyway right in front of me.
Take your pills if I can even.
Run, run, run, run.
Oh, God.
I can't run anymore.
stamina run run run run run run where's my pills take my pills take my pills okay maybe they're not following me anymore i saw something over in that yard too i couldn't grab it though too scary why can i look at the sign real men drink otori beer thank you
Let's see if there's anything over here.
Oh, wait.
Actually, I have to go this way, I think.
Maybe?
Gosh.
That was so bad.
Ah!
If it's just one, though, maybe it's okay.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Nice dodge.
Yeah!
Oh my god there's so much combat in this game it's kind of insane
I wonder where it puts me back at all the way here okay
this is fine man
That's one thing I heard of a complaint about this game was like the combat gets like especially towards the end there's so much combat i'm gonna look for more items while i'm here aha aha thank you thank you
if you can beat this you can beat dark souls is that the consensus
is that the consensus now all right this off okay uh what was it here we go
gosh okay so we know that there's three i just have to run away from them but i know where to go this time now uh when i get to the steel yard i turn left okay
I wonder if I have a...
Wait, no.
If I have a tool repair kit?
I have one!
I could use it on the sickle.
Let's try it.
Wait, full.
What do you mean full?
Maybe I switched...
Oh.
Oh, halfway?
Okay.
I think I'm just gonna run for it.
We're running, we're running, we're running, we're running, we're running, we're running.
I'm dodging.
I'm not dodging.
I'm running.
I'm dodging.
Oh shit, wrong way.
I'm running.
They're not following me.
They're... uh... following me?
They're not following me?
They're... not following me?
Winner.
Yay.
Oh, God, she scared me.
Wait, you were over here the whole time?
Okay, please help me!
I'm scared!
Aibo!
Oh, Dinko looking real sussy over there.
More higashi.
Wait, what's over here though?
Jump scare?
A shoulder bag?
Increases inventory capacity!
That's huge!
Huge!
Let's stay away from there.
More stuff.
Awesome.
I didn't even have to use any capsules.
Actually, did I get hurt?
No, we're good.
Oh,
so scary.
Oh, why is my controller?
Oh, it's this thing again.
Let's not.
I don't think we can beat it.
That would be nice, avoiding the town.
So how's my placement?
I forgot to ask if I'm not so badly in the way or anything.
If you guys can see.
Wait, you're just going to leave me in the middle of the street with that thing behind me?
Yeah, let's go.
Cut through alleyways.
Wait, what's my journal saying?
Middle school.
I'm not blocking anything.
Okay, cool.
This is the middle school that I attended.
It was built when the town was financially well off during the dam construction.
So the beautiful facilities are at odds with the rest of the dull buildings in town.
I think I met Nico during my first year here.
I remember her surprise when she heard that I called Shu Ibo.
Partner.
Howdy, partner.
Okay, so we're going through...
Allie...
Wait, where's the current object?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Cut through alleyways.
Uh.
Okay.
I don't...
Are they not going to be on the map?
The fact that I can hear that thing behind me is, like, so scary.
That's cute.
Looks like I could pick that up.
Oh, my God.
We need to just run.
Where's the alleyways, please?
This way.
Alleyway.
Yeah, kuso for real.
Some actual shit.
Kuso for real.
Okay.
Alleyways.
Towards every sokauk, I'm going to school.
Everything is, like, blocked off this way.
I guess we just keep going.
Oh my god.
Time to fight.
I'll try to grab that.
Ooh, it's...
It's losing, what's it called, real fast, though.
It's so good!
Oh, it's so good, though.
The sickle is so good.
Dang.
Ah, I took it!
Lucky, so lucky.
Awesome!
Ah, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay, we're good.
Yeah, it kills them so fast.
It's so good.
I thought I saw something else, but I might have been seeing things.
You know what?
It's fine.
Wait, is this a...
Ah!
And where am I supposed to go?
just climb over it
like i'm getting further away think about locking enemy oh i forgot about locking on sorry it's been like a minute since i last played
where am i supposed to go then through alleyways but like huh
surely it's not it wouldn't make me go like that far around like over to here no this is so it says this is blocked the things open up all the time so it's kind of like actually before we do that though there's that save we'll go there
was this an item no just rushed stop calling us charlie it's a nice name
save Okay, got through the alleyway.
I feel like I'm just being...
I feel like I'm...
What's the word?
Overthinking it a little bit.
We could get rid of some Higashi.
I don't remember what it does.
Restore stamina.
Guys...
Hint.
Hint, please!
Wait.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Is that not the one that was just chasing after me?
Don't notice me.
Wait, how do I lock on again?
How do I lock on again?
Ah!
I got it.
Oh, shh!
I think I had no stamina.
Ew.
Ouch.
Die!
Oh, it's dead.
Hate.
So punishing.
Alright.
I'm just gonna go forward then.
So like, someone's like all east but this is west i don't know hint is east i'm turning around
i'm turning around we're good the opposite way why can't i just like what if this is why are there stairs if this is not a gate that's what i'm wondering
so i didn't even need to turn back around if that's the case perhaps they're really gonna make me go all the way around okay wait because that's where the truck was no yeah the truck is ah ha ha ha see i told you things are opening up all the time yeah got pushed aside
i love she didn't even say anything
catch up with shu and ninko again okay where are they my friends don't go nobody nobody ever tells me where they go
i'm looking for human bodies that's down here maybe an item hopefully not a jump attack leave me alone i'm just a ghost Please!
Oh, I see it in the...
I see it in the water.
Okay, we turn around.
You can't get me.
I mean, you can.
But not there.
What's that?
What was that?
Oh my god.
Are you just coming up here?
Come on.
I thought these things were supposed to be blind.
How do they notice me?
Maybe it is blind.
Stupid, never mind, just kidding.
You're not blind.
Oh, oh, oh, how did you notice?
I'm standing here quietly.
Ah, nice.
I'll tell you though, I'm not sure I'm a fan of the combat.
Maybe, I don't know.
Maybe I just don't like Silent Hill games.
Maybe that's it.
I thought I heard the sussy noise coming from over here.
Do I investigate?
Question.
Because I don't remember.
Does the shrine heal me?
When I go pray?
I don't think it does, does it?
heals your sanity on story mode okay okay let's go check it out
I'm just oh
where are my friends where are my friends I don't think I'm on story mode I don't remember what I'm on normal mode child Chocolate!
What is my health?
Actually, we can probably take a pill.
Take a peel, take a chill peel.
What's this?
I got it.
Anything else over here?
Like a thing to repair?
Toolkit?
Do I need toolkits around?
I'm collecting toolkits now.
It's my main source.
My friends are missing.
Oh, I remember this area.
Oh, this area sucks.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah, this is, like, kind of where we first started-ish.
I remember.
Okay.
Ah!
It just says catch up.
Wait, okay, hold on.
What if I do?
Oh, catch up with Shu and Rinko at the middle school.
Idiot.
Dummy.
Oh, my gosh.
It's ugly.
It's pretty ugly.
It's going to come back over here, though.
It's gonna notice me.
I like watching the move though.
They're so freaky.
The monsters in this game are so...
Actually, I have to go that way.
Um...
Could you please?
This is the right way?
Okay, thank you.
I'm too scared to explore in this game.
The way they like, Twitch?
Ugh.
Oh, it hurts so good.
Oh.
I took one step.
That's so funny.
Oop.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
No, no.
I'm trying to move.
Oh my god.
The lock-on kind of screws me up, though.
I'm not gonna lie.
I can't!
Ah!
Oh, okay.
Just kidding.
Oh, please, please, please.
Wait.
Ah, shit.
Please, take your pill.
Wait, I don't know what that just did.
Oh, nice.
Ouch.
I tried to dodge, but I'm stupid.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Okay.
Block on.
Where are you?
Wait.
Block on.
Okay, there we go.
Yeah.
Oh, oh, I can't get my dang bearings in this game sometimes!
Okay, I think I got it.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Holy moly.
Let's just, uh...
When did I switch weapons?
Probably out of Scaredy, Scaredy Catness.
Out of button mashing.
We'll stick with...
I don't want to like waste it, but...
Oh wait, look at that!
A new pipe.
Let's switch out this pipe for this pipe.
Yeah, there we go.
Panic swap.
Yeah, I like panic mashed trying to get through the...
Trying to find my way over here.
Oh, I see.
Thank you so much for letting me get to take you!
Thank you so much!
All right.
Is that...
I feel like...
Probably the ways have opened up now.
Probably things have opened up.
I hear something though.
I hear...
What?
Why are you in there?
What's going on?
What?
What's flying?
What's going on?
How did you guys get in there?
Ikki, nasty, nasty.
Sorry, I know I'm like constantly moving the camera around.
I'm checking for enemies and I'm also checking for items, so I'm like very sporadically just...
My eyes are darting left and right.
What's happening?
I love vase break dot mp3.
And if I miss something, please feel free to point it out to me.
That was so funny.
Wait, that sound like totally took me out of the environment.
Oh, did you see that guy up there?
Oh, no.
was the guy that was that was making the horrible noise earlier too oh yeah a hundred percent oh gosh oh the game hasn't given me an excessive amount of pills yet though so maybe i'm saying how much do i have anyway
this game has vine boom wait you're kidding right
Okay, I don't think he's there anymore.
I need to go down the stairs.
But first, what is this?
Peels!
Thank you.
Anything in here?
No?
Don't be scared by the monsters.
Hinako Seifuku continually...
Yeah, we just look at the Seifuku.
Yeah, continually going, is there for you.
The back of her Seifuku has got your back.
Thank you!
I know, look at you guys.
We pointed it out last time, but you guys see the eyes and the tongue going bleh.
bleh.
Yeah, that's a great question.
Oh.
Yeah, where have my friends gone?
Why have they abandoned me so?
Oh, nice.
They like run so...
Fast!
Hinako!
This way!
Are you leading me to a trap?
What do you mean this way?
This way?
This?
Where did she say that from?
She opened a path.
Oh, did she?
I did miss it then.
Oh, right here?
Oh, the thing that's shining really bright.
Oh, thank you, guys.
Aha!
Thank you, thank you.
Kochi?
Kochi.
I don't like it.
I don't want to trust her.
I don't trust if Shu says Kochi, but I don't trust if you say Kochi.
Thank you!
Oh!
Thank you so much for the 50 gifts and thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh, the game just saved.
Okay, I feel better now.
Like, I feel better, but I don't feel better, you know what I mean?
Like, I feel better because I... if I die...
Oh, it's that thing again.
Oh, gosh.
That's the thing.
I don't feel better at all.
Never mind.
I lied.
Ouch!
Oh,
I stunned him, though.
Kind of?
Yeah!
Get his ass!
Oh.
I'm out of stamina.
Please.
Restore.
I'm stuck.
Trying to restore stamina?
Okay.
Die!
Oh, I got him!
Yeah!
First try!
No!
the heck he was there I think honestly I'm not gonna lie maybe because I'm less afraid of him I I'm less scared of him I can fight him more easily than the other than the mannequin ladies a particularly suspicious monster that walks on all fours the greedily staring odd his eyes the greasy palms the disgusting way acts all chummy with me all of it is completely repulsive what's more it never even bothers with guys typical those things look like the liquors from resident evil yeah i see it
is this otaku monster the greedily staring eyes and the greasy palms oh no my palms are sweaty right now is it me am i the monster
Uh-oh.
I forgot about this.
A monster in the form of a Miko or shrine maiden.
It sounds just like Sakuko.
It swings around a spiked mace and chain.
With each swing, the crisp chime of a bell rings out.
Is this actually Sakuko?
Or is this just a monster pretending to be her?
Oh.
Okay.
We're back in.
I wish the game would save again so I don't have to fight him again.
I hear more.
I can't tell if it's squelching from the...
Or if it's like a monster, you know?
Wait, I'm gonna...
Wow, that didn't do like anything.
Anything in there?
No?
Nothing?
Okay.
Yeah, it still owes me 500 yen.
So true!
I was a good friend!
Wait, can I go inside this house?
That'd be kind of crazy if I could.
And by crazy means I don't want to.
By crazy I mean...
Don't make me do that.
Uh-oh.
Bad music?
Where is it coming from?
I can't tell what is meat sound and what is...
Ah!
Get away from me!
Where did you come from?!
Oh, shoot.
Whoa.
Oopsie.
Oh, I got it, though.
Where did she come from?
Okay, nothing over here.
I guess I do have to go up there.
Let's check over here real quick.
Where did she come from?
Oh, wait.
No!
No, don't make me go in!
Okay, we'll stick with...
Well...
I guess we're okay with this for now.
Hold on.
Up here?
There was really nothing?
It just spawned a lady.
I guess.
Nothing over here?
Oh, just kidding.
An antique comb?
Can I offer that?
Is that like an offering?
Hmm.
I wish there was a save point before going into this house.
Oh, no.
It feels too much like going into a haunted house, you know?
Considering they don't really drop anything, the enemy placement level design seems to really encourage confrontation over avoidance.
That's...
Yeah, I feel like that, too.
Oh.
Oh my gosh.
Don't make me go in there.
Like, there's been times I've been able to avoid, obviously.
But most of the time, I'm having to fight them.
It does auto-save.
And here it does.
I'm trusting you.
What am I doing?
Ah!
It did not auto-save.
Face your fears.
Ah!
Go through the house.
it did save though it did save sorry you could see my mouse shouldn't going into a haunted house be super comfy for you though not all ghosts are nice to other ghosts submitting a noise complaint against the hills to the local HOA they're not quiet enough these hills these hills are loud since we're indoors i'm gonna use my My seku.
Because I want to kill quickly.
It's gotten into the house.
What do you...
What... What is it?
What is it?
He went that way.
Ouch, out of the way.
Oh, yes, it's dead.
The music, though, kills me when it...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't say that.
A kitchen knife!
It's frail, so I'll need to handle it with care.
A knife, a light knife for slicing meat and fish that's easy to use.
Should I replace the sickle?
Most damage.
Yeah?
Lost for good.
So sad.
Chocolate.
What does the chocolate do?
Equipment.
There we go.
Bye-bye.
I was like, um, items.
Slightly restores current max sanity.
Insanity will not be consumed.
I always forget about focus stuff, you guys.
I'm sorry.
I forget about it.
Yields a great deal of faith when enshrined.
skull.
There's a lot of health items, but at the same time there's three things you have to worry about.
You have to worry about your stamina, your sanity, and your health.
So, you know, I get chocolate, but I'm like, oh, my sanity is...
Like, I wish it was something for health health instead.
Where did that...
Where did that... Where did that come from anyway, that lady?
in here maybe gosh I'm so scared bandage huge step back girls this calls for a real show of man the hot blooded baseball samurai steps up to the plate
I got it okay okay Me with my baseball bat.
I don't want to turn that off because I'm afraid of it triggering something, you know?
Like a creature being like, hey, you turned off my favorite station.
Bouga, bouga, bouga, bouga, bouga, bouga, bouga, bouga.
Ramanay, hold on, let me also check that.
Sorry.
I'm not stalling.
See, so much stuff for sanity.
She's cosplaying as a Yandere.
This is what Yandere simulator could never be.
it okay
who who was that all right go through the house i'm going i'm going okay i think maybe if i get out well actually i guess it depends where i get out there's a save point
this place is humongous among us wait is that blood leading into that room oh are there somebody's pants?
Uh-oh, somebody... It's the mannequin.
Okay, that way is blocked, so we have to go through there, okay.
That definitely looked like a letter I could read.
More higashi.
Okay, good, we're gonna have a lot to... to pray about.
I sure have a lot to pray about here!
Oh, man.
Yeah, we have to go through the blood door, which is never a good idea.
I'm looking at the photos on the, like, the pictures and stuff.
It's kind of fun.
What kind of house is this?
It seems like...
Like, I'm a little confused.
No, I don't.
Okay, before I go in, guys, I have to go to the little ghosties room.
go to the little ghosty's room because i don't want to get so scared and have well you know i'll be right back it's
so warm in my room so warm in here but i'm gonna tell you guys i'm very happy i'm playing this in the daytime never mind i'm not happy at all that i'm playing this at all um
End combat sequence.
Oh, that's sick.
Is it all the people that were living here?
It looks like it'll throw up.
Yep, I hauled it.
Okay.
Can I even kill this thing?
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
You can?
Okay.
Do I want to or do I want to just leave?
I'm just gonna leave.
I think it's better so I don't waste my knife.
I don't want to waste my knife, you know?
Rinko?
I'm right here!
What?
suffering what what what what are they talking about talk about oh my god wait don't jump down here don't do it where's the okay i
guess there wasn't anything over there oh i can hear it like walking around in the house.
That's so freaky.
Okay, there is a save right ahead.
Ish.
Ew, ew, ew, ew.
I hear, like, things walking all over.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm paranoid.
I'm hella paranoid right now.
Wait.
Can I go that way even?
Oh, I think I can.
Sorry, I keep double checking.
Okay, I want to go save real quick.
I want to go save.
I think it'll let me.
Yes.
Yippee!
Safety!
Okay.
Let's offer the chocolate.
I mean, I could honestly offer the chocolate.
The comb.
We'll do like two of the Higashi.
We'll do one chocolate.
What's the Yohan give me?
Health.
We won't offer that.
Arade, hot health.
and we'll do like a ramen two ramen yeah two ramen
what should we do guys wait do we draw umamori or do we pray
I have one emma
save for the umamori slots what umamori do I even I think I have wait
Yeah, I have one space for...
I have only space for one Omamori right now.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's true.
I think I got stamina before.
That's why it's 800 now.
Health, sanity.
I still don't understand the sanity mechanic.
I think I'm stupid.
Oh.
I'll think about it.
Let me save it.
Let me save.
Whoa, did you see my playtime?
It was very spooky.
Am I going this way, actually?
Wait a second.
No, let's turn around and go try the other way real quick.
Oh, my moori, that turns sanity into HP?
Wait, that sounds...
What the?
I locked onto something.
I thought I did.
Maybe I saw something drop.
Okay, anyway.
I don't know if I can go this way, but I still want to check.
Okay.
Wait.
Oh, yes, we can!
Okay.
I don't know where we're going.
I don't know where my quote-unquote friends are.
Also, this city is so whack.
There's loot on the other side?
Yeah, I do have Omamori equipped.
I do.
I have uh...
This one increases max stamina.
Wait, what's this hand mirror though?
When taking fatal damage from normal attacks, this mirror will break instead.
Health, sanity, and stamina will be fully restored.
Whoa!
Wait, I kind of want to save up...
For a boss.
Wait, that's crazy!
Yeah.
It's okay, I think we can.
can keep going or i think this is the way i need to go check for loot nothing stingy stingy people of this town
oh shit okay oh is there two oh my god oh my god i'm stuck i'm stuck i'm stuck
It's scripted!
Oh, I'm dead.
I got stuck on...
Oh, I didn't realize that the path closed.
Ah!
Holy cow.
Well, let's check down here, then.
Scripted, scripted.
Yeah, let's see.
It seems like this is a dead end, so...
Wait, I'm not sure.
It seems it's very spooky, that's what it is.
Wait, where the hell?
Where am I going?
Map too big.
That's not a box I can open.
Wait, this is where I'm supposed to go!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, good thing we died then.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
Crazy music for just meeting up with my friends.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, this is where we started the game.
Like, or rather, like, when we encountered our first enemy.
Vinko is kind of the worst.
Okay.
I hear something, though.
I hear...
What's my...
Okay.
I guess there probably would have been some sick loot the other direction, but...
It kind of punished me for exploring.
boring, so...
Oh, it's the... it's the...
It's the Otaku!
Otaku!
Hey, Otaku!
Otaku touchy!
Not touchy, no, only one, please.
It's fine, we're chill.
We're cool like that.
Me and this guy.
Okay.
the mountain behind every Sugaoka middle school so we're we're back to trying to go to here okay but what path with what area if meeting your friends triggers music by Akira Yamaoka I'd start reconsidering your friendships I see it an otaku at the bottom right
I feel like your character had to be willfully ignorant of how awful she was to write the entries we read at the beginning it's not like she tries to hide it wait oh what wrinkle maybe I mean it could be that you know people kind of I don't want to say their personalities change but like in situations like this people are going to act different oh wait this all just opened up oh my gosh okay I was like,
wait, do I need to go around?
But nope, I definitely need to go towards this filler.
I was like, do I need to go that way or go around?
We're fine.
It's chill.
Yeah, it's fine.
We're chill.
Silent Hill Pro Tag.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No worries.
Oh, wow.
Back to school.
Yeah, that sucks.
I didn't even do my homework.
Thank you, delinquent.
Oh.
Well, this guy...
We fought him before in an alleyway.
I guess we can, uh...
Do it again.
Wrinkle character details.
Enjoys actively being the most obviously aggressive level of passively aggressive that's humanly impossible.
Okay, here I go.
I'm being brave.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay!
Yeah!
Fear me!
I have a feeling he's gonna, like, jump down at me, though.
Like, right in this area he's gonna ambush me.
Look, they left the dog bowl for him and everything.
Okay.
I was wrong.
I love being wrong.
I like don't trust open areas as much as I don't trust closed areas, you know.
You recognize the kindred soul.
Okay.
His baby.
Throw up baby.
Dried carcass.
Wait, we can offer this, right?
Does each monster have its own music?
Noticing this now.
Sometimes the music sounds different.
Baby man, baby man.
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, why are you on fire now?
Why are you on fire?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ooh, got his ass.
Men on fire.
Go away, baby.
Go away.
Thank you.
My knife, though.
I wonder if I can take this guy out with a bat.
Did you hear the physical release for this game's OSD got canceled?
Wait, why?
Why, though?
You could probably just run past him.
I guess that's true.
Okay.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
He'll leave me alone and then I'll be able to save.
Right?
Yeah.
Easy peasy.
Whoa!
Wait, we can actually almost...
We're 500 away from the increased Omamori.
I don't know what to do yet.
I don't know.
I don't know if I want to go with, like, my own stats or what, you know?
Are you still on your first run?
Yeah, yeah, I am.
I am.
I'm pretty slow at this game, I'm not gonna lie.
I've been definitely taking my sweet, sweet time, because I'm scared.
Omamori are OP.
Okay.
Ducky, thank you so much for the gift, dead!
I did save, right?
I think I did.
Okay.
Anyways, we're in the mountains.
Whoa!
What is that?
Ebisugaoka?
I think
that was usually pretty good with horror.
I'm curious what's so spooky about this game.
Actually, I'm not good with horror at all.
I'm not good with horror.
At all, actually.
If it comes off that way, maybe I'm doing a good job.
Yes.
Pretending to be brave.
Wait, can I go in here?
I don't want to, but I'm asking for a friend.
Okay, good.
I think it's really...
The combat is a little difficult for me.
That's like something I'm not used to.
And then also...
Also...
The tense atmosphere.
Oh, that's a flag.
But I love horror games.
And I love horror in general, so...
Because maybe I love horror games so much, it seems like I'm okay with them.
I'm going to try the other direction.
I don't know why.
You didn't play enough Souls games to be used to the combat?
I've played zero Souls games, so...
Yeah.
I think that's not enough games.
I think so.
I think that's not a lot of Souls games.
But I'm doing my best.
I wouldn't say I'm getting used to it per se, but I'm attempting.
There is an attempt.
Oh, I thought that was a metal pipe.
What's the point of exploration if you're not gonna give me anything?
But I love the atmosphere.
Very much.
If I'm...
Even if I'm not so keen on the gameplay.
Oh, okay, never mind.
What?
Where?
Behind me?
Where did you come from?
Two hits?
That's it!
Oh my gosh, the knife is amazing.
Ah, okay, so I do have to go the other way.
Oh, I got some peels.
the souls guy the timing and movement of this combat makes me weep you're doing well i love it when people that are bad with horror games love playing them yeah well for a long time i would only i watched like i mean there are some youtubers and streamers that i watch that exclusively play horror games and i watch those like almost if not daily and for a long time even before i was a streamer i would watch them like daily and stuff so
Uh...
You know.
But even still, it's different than me playing them, because I can watch and be like, I'm looking away.
Here, I can't do that, which is so sad.
That's from the Obon Festival.
Wait, did I say it's a bit early?
Wait, Obon!
That's like my thing.
Oh yeah, we forgot to look at the baby.
Didn't Minto ever play The Bunker from Amnesia Series.
No, those games stress me out.
A face.
Two faces.
Three faces.
Four.
Put in the Dr. Seuss.
A monster with a thronging mass of faces.
I'm not familiar with any of the faces, yet they seem to know me.
It spouts repulsive things one after the other, violating the peace quiet wherever it goes okay wait i said it updated but i don't know what updated actually maybe characters information oh the lantern evil boarding lantern a type of revolving lantern that has a long history in ebisugaoka the picture silhouette rotates inside the can't the can't the lantern due to the air current that the candle makes oh normally revolving lanterns are for entertainment but the ones in ebisugaoka were specifically used to ward off evil in ebisugaoka there is a custom where women in unlucky ages hang it on the front door during obon what is oh unlucky age is like if i guess you're 44 or something
originally actually i wanted my 3d live to not be well it wasn't originally going to be a birthday thing originally was going to be wearing oboe.
Good thing I didn't mention oboe in at all.
Good thing I forgot.
Good thing it's not because it had to get pushed.
Good thing it's because I didn't remember.
Big doors.
So an old lady lives here?
All right one second.
I'm gonna go save real quick since We're right by it.
No, no.
Leave me alone.
And then I also want to...
Maybe...
What do I have?
We have three Higashi.
Nice.
Yeah, no music.
You're not correct.
You're inaccurate.
I'm in no trouble.
Leave me alone.
Alright.
Okie dokie.
It would be interesting if you could enter all the houses, but also it would be terrifying, and I Would not do it because I'm a baby What's my The stamina is not looking so great on our knife you guys.
I'm gonna switch to the bat for now If we encounter a big boy, I'll switch to the knife, but For anything that's not a big boy, I think I gotta be little more um oh my he scares me every time i gotta be a little more stingy oh we're right here though wow a locked door is always the most comforting thing in a silent you're right
what is happening why
What?
What about me?
Huh?
I'm a ghost?
Whoa.
They said this was like a new fancy in middle school, right?
at all right it should be nice and modern and easy on the eyes right should
be nothing spooky scary about it at all it's more space wars you gotta be kidding me not to brag but we've taken down the enemy's mothership the giant UFO on many occasions however each time that happened the galactic imperium would deploy more and more troops from their whole planet as we grew older we were able to have a better understanding of heroes by watching television and i think we came up with this with some elaborate backstories for the enemy leaders by this time it was the only it was a world that only shu and i knew not to brag but um my invisible demons yeah i beat them up
I'm pretty tough when I'm fighting, you know.
My inner demons and all.
Wait.
I definitely see something on top of this.
But I can't tell if it's moving or not.
I definitely see something on top of that, though.
Maybe I'll go check it out still.
Oh, my gosh.
One sec.
Oh, just kidding.
Okay.
Why don't you just jump it?
It's not even that tall.
OG Silent Hill does have a UFO ending, so this space door stuff could be kept on the way to school.
The little spare...
Oh, I couldn't read it.
I couldn't read the achievement fast enough.
I'm sorry.
Something about a little sparrow.
How have they been so fast if this is how he's been moving too?
Same.
Actually, Rinko's kind of relatable here.
I got it.
I'm tired, too.
Please stay here.
I'm going to stay here.
I'm going to find the door.
I got it.
What?
What's wrong?
No!
Wait, so if Hinako is dead, but she can still- No!
Wait, so if Hinako is dead, but she can still- I don't care.
No, please let me rest.
Oh my god.
You don't have to show up.
shut the door i should look for the keys to the bucket like i thought maybe she was like she's dead because she couldn't like but she's been responding to her and stuff so i'm kind of confused abysugaoka middle school this is oh wait uh abysugaoka used to be a lively town with an ample labor force for construction and coal mining when the school was built the town was always bustling and the school was full of students the students at the time studied how to further improve the students of our time now study so that we can leave to go to a bigger town when we're adults.
Oh, yeah.
It's like a problem now with all these small um, what's the word?
Small cities and all.
I have all the kids growing up and leaving to go to Tokyo and stuff.
Did you guys hear that?
Wait, is this the entrance?
Do you guys hear that?
Spooky.
This was very quiet.
Maybe the game is too low for it to pick up.
Ah, I see, I see.
Oh, okay, so that is the entrance.
Okay, okay.
Look at the little drawings are so cute.
It wasn't breathing.
It was like a...
Oh, wait, there we go.
Oh.
I was like, wow, it's so bright!
No, I'm scared.
Actually, I don't like it.
It's...
I don't...
When there's light, when there's darkness, I don't like any of it.
Bold alert to real!
What?
Can I just leave?
Okay, bye.
Who needs a key?
Why don't I just leave?
Ah!
It pays to explore.
Oreg army of rumors.
Next thing someone heard my prayers.
To whichever god who answered them, thank you.
It's the Oreg army killer.
origami of grievances oh there's a custom that's said to get rid of your worries like magic you write grievances that you can't tell anyone on a piece of paper fold it into an origami fox and then throw it somewhere that no one else will find it if you happen to come across someone else's origami of grievances you can put it to rest by reading it no matter what's written on it you have to keep the information to yourself and not tell a single soul
that's been in this town for ages, but it was particularly popular with middle schoolers.
Some kids would indirectly bully others by writing gossip about the person they hated and making sure to put it in a place they would see it.
I personally don't like to write bad things about people or read them for that matter.
They say that you can put those complaints to rest by reading them, so I make the effort to read them out, but to be honest, I'd rather not pick them up when I see them.
Wait, uh...
Is it like a collectible?
A document?
What's it say?
Gutsikuyo is an ancient practice within Abisugaoka.
First one writes the grievances, they hold inside their heart upon the sheet of paper, then they make the prayer into the foxes.
If we're leaving the paper in a place, no one will find it.
Oh, I guess that's what it wrote, what they wrote.
Interesting.
Oh!
Nice.
Nanashi needs to confront the bad origami writers.
I still have faith.
I'm still thinking of what to do.
Okay, we'll just leave it as we have it.
What's over here though?
So much to explore.
I hate that.
I don't like that at all.
Freaks me out!
What's that?
Yeah!
For me to sell.
Why would they put that there?
For me.
Hi Minto and chat.
Hi Rees!
I like how the ghost emoji kind of blends into the super chat color.
Yay!
Offer, offer, offer, take this dry chicken!
We could totally offer like one thing, like a chocolate, and hit the 1500 we need for the increased Omamori slots.
But at the same time...
What Omamori do I have?
so right now i have increased oops we have the increased stamina i could do increase max health greatly decrease focus charging time that might encourage me to use it more maybe decrease enemy line of sight and then greatly decrease the damage taken while dodging Hawk is OP.
I could get it and try it.
Let's try it.
Let's do it.
Why not?
Oh, your prayers were heard.
You can now equip more Omamori.
3,000!
Oh, yeah.
I just have to remember to do the focus.
Holy, it's so fast!
Wait.
Oh my gosh, that actually makes a significant difference.
Focus, Vittobar.
I am, I am!
Wait, who was I...
Oh, I was like, who was I going to attack?
It's because I was focusing.
is built on stilts.
Anything over here?
No.
Wow, wee.
That's what I was hearing.
You guys hear it now?
The rattling of the window?
Okay, I guess we can't just leave.
That really sucks, but...
Okay, wait.
Can you guys remind me how to use the...
Wait, I can just read.
I can read.
Wait, where's the journal?
There we go.
I can read tutorials.
I can read, I can read.
What did I miss about?
Oh, examining.
Health, stamina, sanity, dodging, fleeing.
Focus.
Once your focus gauge is full, use RB.
Okay.
She can read!
She's not just blindly trusting chat.
She's figuring out the answers all on her own!
Wait, okay.
I got the equipment.
Okay.
Cool.
I still don't like it.
But a ghost's gotta do, but a ghost's gotta do.
Oh, oh, wow, there's so much...
Wow, this map in particular is looking so classic Silent Hill.
Like, this is what I remember maps looking like in Silent Hill, where it's like a bunch of doors, and they're gonna be like scribbled out, kind of like the ones on the left.
You have entered the dreaded school section.
Wait, is that...
Do people not like this section?
Why?
Oh gosh, I can't read.
What's it say?
I can't read kanji.
Human night.
No good.
It won't budge.
It's fine, just a little spooky.
It's a fun section.
Oh, okay, cool.
I like fun.
Okay.
or something.
Radio static?
All the shoes.
Oh!
Wait, what's going on in here?
I could replace my other steel bat.
Be honest with me, guys.
How good is the bat?
Or steel pipe I meant, but how good is the bat?
Be honest with me.
Teacher journal, the vice principal is so paranoid about his keys that he always takes them with him whenever he leaves.
So it's kind of ironic that he lost the keys to the stairwell.
He's looking for them frantically like a madman.
He had the nerve to ask me to help him find them.
But I'm the one who needs help with this pile of paperwork I have.
I love how Bat is great and Bat is meh.
Write two comments right next to each other.
Bat is stronger, pipe is faster.
Okay, okay, okay.
You need a key for the key box.
Oh, to all facility on patrol duty.
To prevent students from going to the second floor, please ensure the corridor is locked at the end of the day.
On patrol this week, Vice Principal Matsu.
Okay, so we have probably like a puzzly type thing going on here.
Look at all these shoes.
Yohan.
It's stuck.
Okay.
Duality of chat.
I know.
This is how you know you'll never ever be able to please everybody.
You know?
Because you can ask a simple question as, you know, what's the bat like?
And they'll be like, it's great.
Or, it's meh.
And then you'll get a real answer, like someone saying, the bat is stronger.
But, oh my gosh, Miffy!
It's not Miffy.
But the pipe is faster.
To all students The game known as The Fox's Sacrifice is here by Band Partaking in this recent fad is Forbidden.
Oh gosh, the kids are on TikTok and doing TikTok trends.
Any students caught playing will Have their parents or guardians notified and be Severely punished.
Fad does similar Damage is pipe but has less durability.
Okay, I'm not stalling Goal.
over there or anything?
I'm not stalling or anything.
I'm not stalling going over there or anything.
Wait, what's in this big room?
What is this?
I'm not...
Oh, wait, this is the door that we need to unlock.
We need to get the key.
This is like when they banned Beyblaze in school.
Yeah.
How about school?
Schools probably have like Pokemon cards still banned.
Oh!
Oops.
Why did the music get all bad?
Oh, what's over here?
Uh oh.
Wait, this is an area I haven't been to before.
Uh oh!
Okay, freaky.
I'm brave.
I'm being brave.
Principal?
Vice Principal?
Looks like there's an item here, but I'm scared.
Divine water.
Okay.
So we have four more.
We have to find the Vice Principal for his key.
Wait, is he actually, like, here?
Sonna.
That guy is not actually around.
Okay.
It's gonna be a radio- That scared me!
The little baby!
There's gonna be another radio that tells me some wisdom or something.
Also another window I can hop out of.
School Founders An anecdote.
Buy as much of that mountain's land as you can.
Borrow money if you must, for it will surely bring you great wealth.
after the country commenced their damn construction plan.
And the mountain Mr. Yoneda had purchased was indeed a boom.
He spent every last yen he earned on his hometown of Ebisugaoka.
One result of his generosity was Ebisugaoka Middle School.
Mr. Yoneda donated the Inari statue and housed it inside the small shrine seen on school grounds as his way of saying thanks to the fox that blessed him.
Interesting, interesting.
I like the little...
It's definitely not Miffy, but it looks enough like Miffy that it makes me feel calm.
I really love Miffy, you guys.
Oh my gosh, the little baby scared me again.
Oh, there's something nasty out there.
You hear it?
What is that?
Wait, that's the big guy again!
Okay, let's, uh...
Uh, ignore that.
Oh, the space invaders.
Why does this, like, little baby look so old?
Space wars, yeah.
Am I at school?
No, no, don't say that.
No, it's scary.
That's like the typical...
Oh, God, that baby scared me again.
Holy...
Oh, that's like the- that's like what ghosts say!
No room that opens.
Hate.
Gosh, this area is so spooky, isn't it?
Let's take that.
Bless, bless, bless.
Oh, my health is okay for now, so.
Uh...
An unlocked room.
Yada, yada!
For a shade kit!
Uh-oh.
They give me one health item, it's okay.
Give me more than one?
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, for real.
Don't give me more than one!
Aoi Takashi.
It's okay.
It can't be 8008.
there's only three.
So now that is on...
What?
Am I trying to steal his clothes?
Hmm.
Why is the girl's room flickering?
Okay.
I'm guessing though...
I heard something from in there.
Freaky.
Freaky, freaky, freaky!
I don't like this sign.
I'm guessing, but...
This area is also weak because we can't get into the second...
Oh, wait.
I thought the second floor was, like, off-limits until we got the key.
Oh.
Yeah.
I knew it.
Alright, time to go into the girl's room.
Oh, boys, close your eyes.
Boys, no peeking.
No peeking, no peeking.
Don't open your eyes.
Oh, it won't open without a key.
Another key?
Okay, well, I've gone many places now.
The only thing I feel like I can find somehow is the code.
You may open your eyes.
Oh, wait.
There's also over here.
There's also out this window, which I definitely don't want to do.
Let me go save.
let me go save and then we'll go out the window
because i don't i went mainly i want to save because we marked all this stuff down and i don't want to have to redo it all you know
do you think my friends will um let me go inside the room wait yeah it's up here okay
I try not to run because I'm like, oh, I want to save stamina in case like something jumps out at me.
But I guess in this case, things have been decently quiet enough for me to feel like I can run for right now.
Okay.
I did try.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Here we go!
I don't think it takes stamina to run outside.
Oh, wait, really?
It doesn't take stamina to run outside of combat?
Oh, stamina only drains in combat.
Oh!
What?
I was being careful this whole time with my stamina.
That's why I haven't been running at all.
Oops!
You think you'll notice me?
Do I have to, like...
This looks...
Oh.
He immediately noticed me?
Wait, though.
I wonder if I have to like run around him Okay
If I die, I die Oh, I'm stuck What do I have to do this time?
Let's see
I'm exploring Against my Against my better judgment Is what I was going to say?
The place is huge Yeah Come here.
Come on.
Oh, shoot.
Did I take her out?
Yeah, okay.
Oh, my focus!
You're right.
Wait.
Wait, is that the big baddie?
Oh.
Come on, fine!
Good.
Wait.
Where did I come from?
Where have I?
Oh.
Uh.
Eww!
Am I gonna hear them, I think?
Like talking smack about me?
Oh, it's...
Baby.
I'm a little lost.
Eww.
Big batty in the bottom, right?
Oh, okay, that goes around.
Oh, the circles around.
interesting okay but is there anything out here i feel like i've covered the whole area maybe i need to actually go to the shed maybe there's something in there we'll wait for him to leave a little bit longer and we'll run past i mean there has to be something out here otherwise it would be silliness to have it you know wait in here maybe the lady came from?
Oh, nice.
Ah, no!
Uh...
Shoot.
There's a ghost even on the map screen!
Oh!
Ah.
Ah!
Dang it.
Wait, so I focus.
Oh!
Ouch.
Did I kill him?
What's he doing?
Zah, zah, zah.
Whoa!
Oh my god, he's...
Oh, I got him.
Whoops.
Wrong button.
Oh, so, okay.
I haven't actually had to fight him so far, I think, so...
Emma!
Okay.
My weapon's about to break!
Oh, shoot, it is.
Uh...
Oh, that's no good.
And big baddies coming this way.
Oh, I hide.
And I guess we can replace it with the pipe.
To my right?
What's to my right?
Over there?
That little shrine area?
Saw a sledge on your right.
What?
Oh, this?
Oh, it's not equipped.
I think.
Dude was minding his own business dealing with poison ivy allergy reactions.
No!
No, he...
Oh, oh, that!
Oh, sledgehammer!
Oh, I see!
It packs a devastating punch, but its weight makes it hard to wield.
I will attempt to use this.
I'm not sure if I'll be very good at it because I'm not very good with, like, the super heavy weapons, but...
I will try.
Hold RT to unleash a powerful attack.
The longer the attack is held, the more brutal it will be.
While using focus, you will remain where you are and take a defensive stance.
Oh, this will allow you to block most attacks, but your weapon's durability will decrease much faster.
When your focus gauge is full, use RB to switch from a defensive position to unleash a focus attack.
Neat.
Thank you, guys.
Okay, what I'm gonna do...
Uh...
I want to go sell stuff.
I want to sell things!
Uh...
Wait.
Yeah, I can't get back to the window from over here, so...
I have to go back down.
We'll wait for him to pass again.
I can't carry the carcass, that's the issue.
That's why I want to go sell stuff.
Oh,
we gotta avoid this.
This big boy.
No way.
No stinking way.
Wait, I think I just trapped myself, you guys.
You guys?
I'm in trouble.
Uh, you guys?
I just...
Oh.
Oh my god.
Wait.
There's no...
Can we dodge through it?
We can try!
This is messed up.
This is so messed up.
Wait, this is actually so messed up.
This is so messed up!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, this might be my opening!
Get in through!
Oh my god, I can't believe.
I can't believe I somehow made it.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I went the wrong way.
Uh, shoot.
Wait, we'll do something inside.
Just run.
Ah!
We'll do something inside!
Just go!
That was too scary.
That was way too scary.
Okay.
I'm getting rid of you.
Divine water.
Get rid of you.
All right, we can go back now.
I don't want to.
I don't want to go back.
Especially when they add enemies on top of big enemies.
So mean.
So mean for them to do.
Oh my gosh, that thing goes.
gets me every time.
It's invincible even.
It's the worst.
I think I got everything I can over there.
I guess we just have to look around a bit more again.
Yeah, I need the keys still no i meant sorry when i said over there i meant here this area so i don't want to i don't need to go back all the way over there the shed only had the carcass from what i understand um i did not go into these areas over here so i think there's a hint in the school about where to look is there hold on i'll go read i'll go read what this said again
just says I need the key.
Oh, yeah, that's right.
I can switch my...
Steel.
Oh, wait.
I want to try this bad boy.
Actually, I don't know if this is the right time to try this bad boy, because we're kind of in like a need to get out of there quickly kind of situation, but we'll hold on to it.
Is there anything in here that's had a hint?
I don't think so.
Okay.
Aww.
Alright.
Well, at least he's not like camping just this area now.
He's like walking back and forth, so.
Could be worse.
Just play dead.
Oh, there's two of them.
Is there...
Okay, that one that was there is gone.
Just play dead.
She won't even notice.
Okay.
Who?
Where?
Oh, is it him?
Did he notice me?
I see her, too.
I see another lady walking around.
From where?
He's just making his way up.
I'm gonna go get some more water real quick, you guys.
we'll let it we'll let the hopefully he'll he'll be gone by the time i'm back he's already walking away but hopefully he'll like have made his wait did i refill my hot water thing oh wait i might not even have any hot water
oh no oops uh well yeah i'm about to find out i'll be right back sorry this is my second time walking away i'm so sorry in like 10 minutes even.
Okay, sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Look.
You hear him?
He's walking around.
Stomp stomp in.
With no regard.
Stomp stomp in around.
Okaidii.
Tadaima!
I had no hot water.
I forgot to refill it.
I see you is she the one that i woke up earlier i wonder okay so if i what who is it him noticing me
it is okay all right okay i'm just gonna have to
ah okay i'll wait one more time sorry guys ah my timing is so off
Go away.
I'm gonna keep my pipe out just to be.
Okay, go away.
Yeah, this part's a little stinky, but that's okay.
Before going back out, check the second floor stairs for a clue about the key location.
Oh, but I did.
I went to the second floor stairs.
Alright, we're just gonna run.
If I die, I die.
That's fine.
If I die, I die!
Sa, sa, sa!
Aw, shoot.
Okay, I don't think I can go in there.
Sa, sa, sa, sa, everything is running at me.
Everything is currently running at me.
Everything is like running at me so much right now.
I can hear them behind me.
She is right behind me, isn't she?
Sa, sa, sa.
Okay, definitely can't go in there.
We're dodging.
You're playing dead.
I'm smarter than you.
Sa, sa, sa, sa, sa, I'm searching?
Oh, God, he's right there.
Sa, sa, sa, sa.
Ah!
Wait, pick up!
Yeah!
Main building, second floor?
Okay, wait, but I'm in kind of a...
I'm in a bit of a pickle here.
Sa, sa, sa, sa, sa, sa, sa, sa.
Oh, look, this is where they do all the...
Oh, that didn't sound good.
Just keep running.
Oh, shit!
Wrong one!
Here.
Hit
it.
Let me go save.
Oh, it saved for me.
Yippee!
Okay.
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
I can't tell if it's getting closer or not.
Is it?
It doesn't seem like it.
Okay, no, yeah, it doesn't seem like it.
Cool.
Because you usually start streaming, and then for me, I keep thinking it must be like 2 a.m.
at least, then I check, and it's 10 p.m.
Looking for EU-friendly stream, of course!
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Let me through.
You're not gonna attack me, are you?
Are you?
Maybe it's fine.
It's up here, right?
Yeah.
I guess I could also go the other way, but...
Wait, no, this is...
Wait, the key I got...
Hold on.
The key I got is for a second floor, right?
Where is it?
Collectibles.
Yeah, okay, so we don't have the key for in there, which I'm guessing unlocks...
Sorry, I didn't expect them to be behind me either.
Okay.
Don't mind me.
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Maybe we're okay.
I have it!
I have- I have the key!
Wait.
Do I-
Use.
Use the key!
Oh, this is the annex.
It's not the second.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
Okay, so we have to decide which way we want to go.
Pick our poison, I suppose.
Oh.
Either way doesn't seem great.
So...
Let's go this way.
It's closer to the save.
I wish I could tell.
I wish they would, like, twitch just a little bit, you know, sometimes.
No, I forgot to get the carcass!
Oh, shoot.
I forgot to get the carcass.
Deciding if I want to go back out and get it?
Dang it.
Yeah, I know I still can.
I'm just deciding if I want to do it.
Surely I'm close enough.
Yeah, that you're fine.
Don't do anything when I turn around.
Oh, gosh.
They're so scary.
This one looks like trouble, though.
What are you staring at?
This one looks like trouble.
This one, I think, is going to attack
me.
Wait, do be dodging?
Okay.
Alright.
Maybe they were just...
Maybe they're all fine.
Maybe they're just introducing you that they're now here.
And you...
You will be sad.
Oh, wait.
I forgot that it just auto-saved.
But that's okay.
that's fine I'm still deciding if I want to go back out we'll decide we'll decide but let's go upstairs first
oh yeah telling you school is no longer safe do
that wait what's here nothing thanks a whole bunch thank you so much
all right let's see what we got what's the damage here oh these are well this one is open
my old classroom oh that means there's something really bad in there
oh yep
wait is this this isn't like the in Silent Hill 3 that fills up with gas and he can't get out, right?
I sat here and behind me was Dinko.
She used to give me the right answers.
Hinako isn't...
Oh, unopened envelope.
Hinako isn't coming.
I'm sorry for lying to you.
But I thought that I needed to get you alone to find out how you truly feel.
Look into your heart and try opening this box.
with your true feelings.
Do you remember that day when just the two of us went to that cafe?
We talked about how it felt like we were delinquent since we were supposed to be going to school that day.
But you know what?
I didn't care what the other people thought about us because as long as I could spend time with you, that was all I needed.
We both ordered the same cake that day.
I can still remember how my heart almost burst out of my chest the moment the same words flowed from those lips.
The sweet and tart fruit on the cake.
in my mouth like it was yesterday.
Do you still remember the taste, too?
Ooh, la, la, opened the puzzle box.
Okay.
Oh, wait, you were...
Oh, it's an actual puzzle box.
Oh, okay, it's one of these where you, like...
Have to, like...
Okay, we have to, like, slide it.
Ah, wait!
What did I just play recently that had something like this?
Okay.
So we need to select the fruit, it seems.
Is that tamagozushi?
Everything...
Sweet, maybe?
No.
It was Nancy Drew!
Uh...
Is this not...
Wait, maybe the pie?
Ah!
Looks like this...
This room is filled with a different kind of toxicity.
Poodoots.
An opened envelope.
So you did remember.
Well, that makes me feel very special.
By the way, are you over Hinako now?
I apologize if I sound blunt, but I want to make it clear.
That girl is dead.
I know you're going through a rough time right now, and you must be in so much pain.
But you know I can be there for you.
Would you rather go through it yourself still?
Took you 20 minutes.
It's you just picked the fruit.
All you do is pick the fruit.
I can picture a slowly unfolding the pages of our hearts, talking about all the small mundane details of our day-to-day lives.
By filling up one journal after another with our thoughts, I know we can make a fresh start.
A blank page upon which we can write a new story of our lives.
Surely you can see it too.
Oh, oh more?
Okay.
Starewell.
The vice principal is so paranoid about his keys that he always takes them with him whenever he leaves.
It's kind of ironic that he lost the keys to the stairwell.
Oh, okay.
That was what we read earlier.
And then this is the secret box.
So I'm guessing just paint the books.
Oh.
Does the origami count?
Maybe not.
Maybe the letter doesn't count because it's not blank.
Okay.
Unopened envelope.
I'm glad to hear that you're trying to stay positive.
And remember, I'll always be here for you if you need anything.
You know, you're not the only one who's sad because Hinako is no longer with us.
If the two of...
typo.
If the two of us could huddle together, we could soothe this pain that bites like the cold of winter.
And then surely spring will arrive, welcoming us with Sakura in full bloom to celebrate our union.
Can you picture the beautifully blooming Sakura awaiting us?
This girl is kind of...
I'm guessing cherries don't count even though it's like a cherry blossom.
I'm guessing it doesn't count.
Actually, what counts here?
There's a lot of plants.
You're not the only one who sad Hinako is no longer with us.
Sakuko is sad too.
Doesn't it look like the two meteors from your name?
Okay.
Maybe it's only flowers.
And then these are cherry blossom petals, you can tell.
Oh, wait.
So maybe it's actually only the cherry blossoms themselves.
Whoops.
Not bad.
Oh.
Dear Shu, I like you.
I love you.
I always have and I always will.
I'll be waiting to hear what you think about me.
Oh, second floor classroom generic key.
It might unlock the classroom.
Oh, Shu hasn't read this letter.
Okay.
What else we got in here?
Or a Garmi!
She should just disappear.
someone kills her or abducts her abdux ducks ducks her i don't care just whatever gets hinako out of my life once and for all is this rinko's handwriting oh my god you guys were right she was oh i'm guessing that okay yeah that says dinko and shu and this is like those umbrellas the like the love umbrellas wow wow she's like actual yandere i bet behind the scribble says hinnako she's actually yandere oh oh wait that's junko who is junko oh her sister
oh Oh
no, the school's all messed up now.
Explore the school's second floor!
Yuppie!
I maybe should have explored before it turned to flowers.
Maybe.
It looks like Shu hasn't read this letter.
That's funny.
Aw, man.
Wait, was there anything else in here that I missed?
I don't think so.
Oh, cat.
Oh.
What the hell?
Where did that come from?
Ew!
Rico, you're such a freak.
This is a dead bird.
Wait.
Is that a sparrow?
Because I...
Wait.
hold on.
I was watching like an explanation of everybody's names.
I was watching a video of an explanation of everybody's names like the other day of this game.
I think Hinako no because no who was it?
One of them had
one of them had like one of them was Sparrow but I don't remember Hinako is baby bird.
But I thought it was that...
Wait, isn't that the...
Isn't that the kanji though for Hinamatsuri?
Game over screen has the bird on it.
You're right!
You're right, you're right.
Oh my gosh.
The lighting is like so crazy.
Spooky.
Yeah, it's kind of bad.
Oh, it just saved.
That's also bad.
Don't like that.
This looks important.
Final exam.
Fourth place, Asakura Ayumi.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, wait!
479!
That must be her thing!
Nice toolkit.
That must be...
Wait, but it was Aoi, no?
The locker code.
Wait, but...
that was maybe the guy has a crush on her and made her score or something like his combination what was it wait
479 479 479 okay I'm gonna go back downstairs and hopefully not die there are more lockers oh there are maybe oh I haven't gone been able to go into the girls locker room yet so Maybe that's why.
Sometimes I really can't tell what is sound of...
of meaty flowers and what is sound of spooky...
A spooky creature walking.
You know.
I'm scared.
I'm checking all my angles.
We go in, hesitantly.
Okay.
Maybe?
Oh, what's this?
Old Anna- Ah!
Wait.
Oh, no.
Wait, now that I've gotten that, I feel more scary things are going to happen.
No!
Note to teacher.
Ayumi from the track and field club said she found a key with key box written on it during practice.
If she still hasn't gotten it back to you, then she probably left it in her locker when she went to change.
To be honest, I shouldn't be surprised if she forgot.
Exhausted after practice.
Open the locker in the locker room.
Bandage.
I'll take that.
Thank you very much.
Anything else?
Maybe not.
Spooky music.
Spooky.
Spooky, Spooky, don't mind.
Oh, it's spooky.
What?
Oh, this is their schedule.
I was like, what?
That's so much kanji.
Oh, God.
No, this schedule is insane.
Winter break.
What is that?
The Hina and her name has the same kanji in Hinamizawa as well.
Woo-woo-woo.
Yeah.
Kanji, no.
Is there even a kanji?
Let's see.
Kanji class.
There's Ago.
I don't see it.
If there is.
Just at a glance.
Kanji scares me too, don't worry.
I'm so bad.
I knew it.
As soon as I picked up...
As soon as I picked up that key, I knew.
Oh my god.
I knew.
I knew I should have explored before picking that up.
I knew it, I knew it, I knew it, I knew it.
Ah!
Well, we've had a good while without having to touch any monsters, so...
It's so cool looking.
Wait, how do I...
It's such a good visual, it's so cool.
Whoa.
I didn't read what room this was.
Oh, there's a bunch of toys, though.
What's this?
Oh, my gosh.
Tee-tee is the most disgusting person I've ever met.
I wish someone would destroy her locker.
If anyone wants to make my wish come true, her locker combination is 3-7-7.
Tee-tee.
Oh, it's so bad!
Higurashi real!
Uso da!
Um, what was I gonna?
I...
Oh yeah, I was gonna check the...
It seems that making secret codes with numbers and symbols is all the craze these days.
What?
When did I read that?
Wait, when did I read that?
I heard that.
Oh.
Liar, liar, liar, liar, liar.
I personally would have localized that as liar, liar pants on fire, but that's just an artistic choice of mine.
Scary!
So scary!
Yeah!
I think your version captures the nuance better.
Yeah, there's just like, you know, some things are just really hard to, you know, localize.
They have deeper meanings than just being translated directly.
And I think saying liar, liar, pants on fire, really just demonstrates the gravity of the situation.
You know what I mean?
Oh my gosh, the map!
It's so cool.
Boyd, I wonder if the origami in this room, because it showed the, what's it called?
The combination of the locker?
If that's a lie, if you don't believe it.
Okay, I'm, like, way scared.
And I have a, I'm definitely looking like Hinako right now, rubbing my arm, being like, But I feel like maybe it's better to be attacked by only one guy instead of potentially three.
So, I'm going to take a sipy and we're going to be brave.
Bravery!
Bravery rewarded me!
Wow, it's getting really bad in here, though.
It's getting sticky, sticky situation.
Wait, can I even go this way?
Oh my gosh.
I can't see it.
That's scary.
Oh, that's scary.
I don't know if I checked over here.
I don't like it.
I still can't...
Okay, yeah.
But where did all the creatures go here?
Doesn't look scary to you, yeah?
Wow, Chucky, you're so brave.
Oh no!
We missed out on the carcass.
Dang it, I should have gone back.
That's my bed.
That is absolutely my bed.
Oh, and now...
now the lights on here.
Wait.
Is that someone hanging from the... Yes, it is.
That is somebody hanging from...
Oh, there's a couple girls.
A couple people hanging from the ceiling.
Wow.
The visuals in this section are immaculate.
They're so stinking good.
Okay, we still don't have this.
Yeah, okay.
So I'm guessing we get one...
I'm surprised these are alive.
We get probably the key and to get the key in there to get the key to there is my guess.
It's so good.
I'm loving the visuals in this area!
It's so scary!
It's so good, so good.
Sorry.
Okay.
Whoa.
checking my corners checking my corners okay all right actually I'm going to go save if that's all right you guys that game has an auto saved in a minute and I think I want to sell some stuff I think This section is very, very neat.
I like it a lot.
I'm quite a fan.
It hasn't spread, I guess, a crazy amount in this area.
Okay.
We'll just save over that.
And then...
We got a lot of Arate.
It restores health, but...
We'll get rid of like...
three of them?
That's like nothing, but whatever.
It's fine.
If all I can hold is five, I want to have more...
Actually, I don't know how much I can hold, but it's okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's like a tiny amount of health, and there's also a tiny amount of offering that we get anyway, so...
Okie dokie!
Yeah, they did cook with this area.
It's so spooky.
So scary.
So, so scary.
Alright.
Anyway, a gas.
Well, let's see.
Oh, there's only two doors I can try, so let's do the close one first.
I say that because the further away one probably has important stuff.
More scribbles.
Um, what is that?
Well, some sort of letter or something.
Oh, another toolkit!
Huge!
Wait, I could heal my knife.
Because we have two.
We'll do that before I, like, forget to, you know.
Alright.
Maybe, okay.
Walk around.
Little entrance for us, thank you.
What?
I hate this game.
Well, uh, wait.
It's square root of six is three, right?
No, wait.
Oh, I don't know!
So, Miki.
I give up.
Miki learned square roots yesterday in class and said, this is my entire personality now.
It's actually what happened.
Note from a male student.
It's the code for baka, so you know, stupid.
Girl code is based off the alphabet.
Girl code.
Basically, you just switch letters with numbers and symbols that look like them.
So Sato would be, 5, 4 plus 0, 6.
5 looks like S.
And 4 looks like...
This is just Leet speak.
And the plus is T.
Wow, I wonder...
What...
How did they...
How...
What the original is like, you know, in Japanese?
The 0 is O.
Because they're basically the same shape.
6 doesn't really look like it, but apparently it's...
you so for my name Yoshida it would be x05174
okay a uh a i s i
T, B.
I don't know what the hell the square root is supposed to be
I don't think it's Aish that do you guys unless it does say that it's a love note but it says XOXO
Aish Oh, instead of the plus being...
Oh, wait.
Oh, Aishiteru.
Oh.
Damn, you're saying that in middle school?
Girl is serious, serious.
Dang.
Yeah, Aishiteru makes sense.
What's that?
This is...
Okay.
Note between lovers, Miki.
I have absolutely no idea how that crazy formula spells Aishteru.
But I love you too.
Miki, you're...
Girl, you're kind of crazy, but...
Me too, I guess.
The absolute vibes of that note.
So funny.
I don't like it, I don't like it!
I think I hear something breathing, but...
I could be extremely paranoid.
Okay.
Alright, before we do that...
Oh, we're searching for somebody's desk.
Okay.
Oh, geez.
Oh,
lock a room key!
Asakura's textbook.
I am a tortoise.
The bus is calling out to me.
I didn't get the news that school would be so far away.
Bus?
Bus!
The best thing in the world!
I love it so much that I made it my locker combination.
Moment of silence for the localizers.
They just totally...
They completely gave up.
Even translating Aishiteru.
They were like, if you're playing this game, you probably Wait, no, you wee-a-boo.
Orgar me of grievances.
Oh, how I wish I could just climb inside his locker and drown in his smell.
I can't believe his combination is the same as his name.
Ow!
Oh, so 401.
That's so cute of him using his name and code.
Okay, there's so many locker combinations.
Wait.
It's chocolate.
Lots of chocolate around these parts too.
Asakura Ayami.
Roll four line two.
Well, I already...
I mean...
I didn't need to read it.
She's so real.
Boy smell, boy smell!
I wish I could just hide in his locker and bask in his gym clothes.
Does Minky need to go read some Mega Tokyo to brush up on her lead speak?
Clearly I do.
Okay, so there's probably...
Ouch, I keep biting my tongue recently.
Alright, mannequins!
Aha, there you are.
I knew it.
I knew you'd be here.
You're following me.
You like me or something.
Holy!
Get
out!
We stun-locked her before she could do anything.
Dang, this thing- No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I wonder if I could kill it so it doesn't stalk me anymore.
If I- if I kill it, will it stop- keep stalking me?
Will it stop?
Give it a whack.
Again?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Alright, he's gone.
He's gone.
We're safe.
I'm like, I'm not, I will not have you pulling that stunt on me.
They're not all dangerous now, are you guys?
You're not gonna fall from the ceiling, are you?
I have a knife.
Wait, did I?
Oh, no, no, no.
This is...
Okay, just kidding.
Ah!
I get it, I get it, I get it, I get it.
Okay.
Let's go to Aoi Kun first.
A...
I call him...
Okay.
Aoi.
Yeah!
Okay.
Okay!
I got...
Oh, another Orog army!
I happen to find...
out Suga's locker combination.
The weird thing is, when you convert it to code, it looks like a cry for help.
What am I supposed to do?
It's not like I can do anything.
What?
Were there other lockers?
That I could get?
I don't remember seeing any others, but...
I thought it was just the one, guys.
Yeah.
So now we gotta...
Wait, was there anything here?
Okay, yeah.
So now we gotta go to the...
girl's room.
Eew.
I
wish I could shut the door.
Alright.
Whose lockers we got in here?
This used to be my locker.
This is Ayumi.
What was...
Oh gosh.
She had I think hers was probably her score.
Was it 749?
Was that what it was?
Let's try it.
No.
479, thank you.
No?
479 was the score.
So it wasn't that.
Ayumi, ayumi, ayumi.
Bus!
Bus is the best thing in the world.
So, okay, so that's her lock.
Staying hydrated, I miss all that whore.
I am!
Thank you!
I'll take another sip here.
Maybe three.
What was you again?
Six, three, six, five.
five or eight six five eight six six ah why do i keep thinking three for me i should have waited for this one
i should have waited suga
looks like a cry for help And then TT is 377.
Whoever TT is.
Cry for help.
SOS?
Aha!
You good girl?
My school bag is a bit worn out for some reason, but it's fine for carrying small things.
Nice!
Oh, huge, huge!
Why is my school bag here?
That's kind of freaky.
And then this is...
TT!
377.
I feel like something bad's gonna happen here though.
Oh!
Deals additional damage when using weapons with high durability.
Effective only for weapons with durability.
Nice!
And this looks like Ramene, yop, yop, yop.
Yop, yop, yop.
Yes.
Cool!
Cool, cool, cool.
Okay.
She the wolf.
She a lone wolf.
All right, I think I got everything here, so let's, um, face the outdoors.
Oh, I already see somebody standing there.
I couldn't perhaps go up the other way.
Go upstairs and go the opposite way, could I?
I couldn't have... I couldn't go the long way.
Could I?
Maybe.
Oh, gosh.
Scared me, sorry.
I'm deciding.
I'm currently deciding what I want to do.
The durability is already I have, and we've only fought, too.
Let me go upstairs.
And see what the situation looks like.
If it's bad, we'll just go back downstairs.
These ones don't seem to move, though.
So...
Is there anyone up here?
Okay.
I can't again, once again, I'm paranoid because I can't tell if I'm hearing sounds of something walking or flower sounds, you know.
So paranoid.
This game makes me very paranoid.
There was something on the floor to pick up.
Wait, there was?
Where are?
Note on the floor.
Over here?
Oh, I see.
I see it.
Wait, there's a couple.
Wait.
Why?
Wait, guys, this is bad.
Wait, there's so many pills on the floor.
Why?
Gotta go help a buddy move and I don't wanna...
Gotta get a moi-moi cue, moi-moi go!
Rest in glitch phase!
Moi-moi-cune!
Have fun!
Have fun with your friend!
Wait, why are there so many pills?
Why are there three pills?
I'm gonna go save.
Then they will come get them.
It's a bad sign.
If that's 100% like the worst sign you could give me.
Free health?
No.
No, no, no, no.
Ah, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Absolutely not.
We're going to come back for him.
But first, since I did all that work, I want to...
I want to save.
I'm save scumming a little bit.
Okay.
Yippee!
Did I read the newspaper I just passed?
Let me see.
This one?
Wait, I don't see this.
Okay.
Alright, let's go, uh...
Let's go see the damage.
Oh, this one?
Oh, but I...
I don't need this anymore.
anymore?
I already got the...
I already got the key.
Who's gonna ambush me?
In fact, maybe we'll do that.
Because these guys are pretty fast.
If I'm not fast enough, either, you know?
That one, that one for sure is like the trap.
I don't see anything around.
This one's gotta be the trap.
I pick it up and like the guys spawn behind me or something.
I was busy on my birthday on Thursday, so I'm wishing all the best today.
Zikai, happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
We have eight pills!
We don't need it, right?
Nothing?
No, what?
What?
Ah, a comb.
I wish I had seen that before I went to go save.
Feels like a boss room.
As soon as I, like, step across this threshold.
Nothing?
None, that's so.
Okay.
Expectations subverted for real.
The game is just messing with us, isn't it?
I'm gonna go sell this comb.
I'm gonna go sell it.
Because we need as much inventory as we can.
We're at 600!
Wait, we could...
Should we do like an Omamori gacha?
Or I could also increase my abilities.
I could get more health.
I would have really liked more of this stuff.
Like this part of the game?
Yeah, I really like this.
It makes me...
This is like the scariest part of the game so far.
In just terms of like atmosphere and how paranoid I am and everything.
I definitely think atmosphere stuff is my favorite.
So that's why I really like this.
And I'm kind of lukewarm on the combat.
Okay.
We made it.
Ah!
Back...
Key to the back mountains.
Alrighty.
Head back to Shu and Ninko!
I'm just gonna run.
This area is unaffected.
Why?
Uh...
Oops, wrong door.
Wait, where is it this one?
Oh, is this one?
I knew they were gonna be talking smack about me.
What?
Femme Fatal!
You wish.
Oh really?
Really?
Wait, why are you guys leaving?
Wait, what?
Okay, it's time to go to dreams of Foxy's Foxy guy.
Why is she always talking smack about me?
Kyo me neo.
So creepy.
Shell of the past.
What exactly have we learned?
I feel like I'm gonna sneeze again.
Oh?
Wait, what?
Oh!
His mask wasn't on.
Face reveal?
Docs yourself!
Oh my gosh, am I sleeping in his lap?
Whoa!
I forgot you guys could hear that.
Sorry.
She's so cute.
Oh yeah, we drank the fire water.
Oh my gosh, I need to blow my nose.
Bad, bad.
I'll do it after.
Head part.
Yeah?
Don't laugh at me!
What is...
It's like Vader drunk.
Oh.
We're finally going in.
I gotta blow my nose.
I don't have any tissue.
Too much ectopatism.
I think I trust our doll more than trust this guy.
But honestly, do we have another choice?
Isn't this the guy?
Like, the notes all said, like, He knock always mine.
Mine, mine, mine.
I don't trust this guy at all.
I know a lot of people said that they kind of, like, called, I guess, whatever the twist is of this story pretty early on.
But...
Uh, I'm just, I try not to, sometimes I try not to just, like, theorize.
I like to just kind of let the game take me on the ride.
So, I honestly haven't really thought much about it.
Hold on, though.
Let me go get some tissue.
I'm sorry, guys.
I keep having to leave you all.
I had tissue in here, though.
I just don't know where I put it.
My room's not even messy, so I'm like, where could I have put it?
Okay, let me go.
Let me go grab a tissue.
Okay.
I'll grab a tissue pack.
Oh!
I tore it, but it, like, didn't tear properly.
Alright.
I'm not too smart at figuring stuff earlier than, like, one minute before it's revealed.
That's okay.
Sometimes it's just fine to live in the moment.
And, like, you know, just experience it in the moment.
I'm handling the fox guy better than most other vtubers I've seen even if you are sort of into him it's not that I'm into him it's not I'm into lap pillows and he not goes very cute so seeing her in the lap pillow makes me be like yippee
sorry I'm muting for me with my nose okay let's go let's follow this guy
on this guy he's like whatever
what wait what you mean hi wait we're just agreeing we're agreeing to what goodbyes oh i like how this this is like purikura drawing of the vice principle speaking of atmospheric horror i wanted to ask have you ever read fuan no tanne oh my gosh wait i did read that so so long ago Wait,
hold on.
Let me look it up real quick.
I remember the name, but I don't remember anything else about it.
Wait, hold on.
One second.
Fuan.
Fuan no tan.
Yes!
Whoa.
It's like a series of short stories.
Okay.
I remember.
This is the part where I felt the game's quality was dropping.
Oh no!
I guess the school section was so good.
But...
Like, I really, really enjoyed that part.
Oh.
So, the door can't be opened.
Okay, good to know.
Just telling me how, alright?
Oh.
I think I found a way to open it.
Open something.
Wait.
I found a, uh, I opened something.
Go through the door.
Okay, chill.
Hold on.
KFP raid?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, I missed it!
Why KFP?
Hello!
Hello, hello!
Wait, actually?
Did I miss it?
Where did that door open up?
Oh.
Damn.
Aha.
Oh.
Gosh.
Explore the area.
What the hecky?
I like how both of these guys are like,
Kikiriki, Kipirin!
Kikiriki!
Thank you, STM2.
Thank you so much for the game.
I don't
want to go in there.
I don't think I want to go in there.
It was a manual raid.
Oh, thank you.
Thanks for coming.
Whoa.
Phil, thank you so much for the vibe.
Get in.
Welcome in, everybody.
I'm playing Silent Hill F.
It's pretty spooky.
What is this?
I'm just touching.
Okay, we're just pulling levers.
I'm just touching stuff.
I see, I see.
So whatever.
Ah, okay, okay.
It's one of these types of puzzles.
Find the missing object to fit in the device.
Wait!
Are we going to lower wrinkles?
Lower Rinko into the fires where she belongs!
Dorico, thank you so much for the vibe, get this!
Thank you!
Okay.
What is this now?
Oh!
Just kidding.
Yippee!
I still can...
upgrade something.
I'm so mad I didn't get that carcass in the yard.
Ow!
Okay, so red is open currently.
Okay.
Yes.
Oh, and so is green.
Actually, maybe I don't know how this works.
I hope I didn't open the door for that thing.
Oh!
Oh, I don't like that.
Okay.
I'm being brave.
Lala lava.
Binko.
All right.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you so much.
Oh, jeez.
Be careful.
Lala lava.
Rinko.
Oh.
Why do I feel like my...
Thing doesn't like...
Load so fast anymore.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my gosh, she's tough.
Woo!
Oh gosh, I'm trying to walk on you please!
Ouch!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, okay.
Oh, she's down but like not out.
Oh no, okay.
Oh, things don't truly die here.
Oh, gosh, that was spooky scary.
Okay.
What's this?
First aid kit?
Thank you.
How's my...
Wait.
Oh, wait.
I don't have the...
I don't have my knife anymore.
Wait, did my...
Was that my knife?
What?
Wait.
Oh, it's...
Whatever.
Oh, that's why I was like, why is it so...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Oinari is Sama's emblem.
All right.
Different dimension.
Yeah, so different weapons.
Ah, I was like, wait, there's not even like a...
What's it called thing though?
This...
My brain.
Durability.
Yes, I kept wanting to say so.
stamina.
I knew that was wrong.
Alright, let's go this way.
Let's go this way.
Oh!
What?
Aha!
I see!
Okay.
Oh, man.
I think that's the blunt blunt bled from the first time you were here.
Probably.
That's why
Wait, that's me!
I'm the baby!
Anyway.
I'm the baby, I'm the baby.
Oh, gosh.
Let's go through here because I can.
Wait.
Oh, that's the other thing.
Okay.
Whoa.
Rinko's room?
I'm gonna steal her stuff.
We're in Rinko's room?
Why she got a bunch of dolls?
Oh my god, Rinko's smell.
Rinko bed.
Like, how quiet it is in here with just the clock.
No thank you.
Prumpled letter.
for writing you a letter out of the blue.
I know we could just talk at school, but when I'm around you, I always end up...
beheaded.
Whoever wrote it stopped here.
Hey, I know this is really last minute, but would you mind coming shopping with me on Sunday?
I want to know what clothes would look cute on me.
From a boy's perspective, that is.
What do you think?
The letter ends here abruptly.
I love you so much.
You never leave my thoughts.
Rinko.
Girl!
Should have written it in numbers.
Or Seifuku.
Alright.
Let's grab the thing.
Oh.
Rinko collects dolls?
Rinko's got a spooky hobby.
Don't like that.
What are we doing?
What?
Hi!
Oh, red means scary.
What's that?
What did I do?
I guess I just opened the door?
Made it so I could get back out?
Why is it so musty in here?
Girl, don't you wash your sheets?
Your futon?
Come on!
Why is it so...
Stinky!
Oh wait.
Oh.
Things are different now.
I'm back here!
What?
What the heck?
A
puzzle is a foot.
Truly.
wait can i go back this way
you were supposed to find a thing in there okay let's go back wait do i need to oh man okay ah we'll have to go all the way back there okay i should have searched more thoroughly that's my bad
luckily it's very easy to get there
oh geez we'll go back Oh, sometime.
Yes.
Oh, what's in here?
Ah!
Ow!
Shit, shit.
Ah!
Oh,
my god, my stamina.
Oh my gosh.
I should have died.
Just my bad.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna die!
It's okay.
Now we know.
Oh, okay.
I did not handle that well at all.
But maybe this thing is not where I need it to be now.
Maybe it's somewhere else.
Just kidding.
Oh my god!
Oh,
my stamina.
Okay, come here.
You have- Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, okay.
Ah!
She gets me before I can get her!
Yeah!
One for extra pleasure.
Is it dead?
I don't think truly.
Oh, I don't like these areas, though.
This part.
I don't like it.
Okay, let's go back into the room.
One second.
Yeah.
Wait, do I need to do it all over again?
No.
Okay.
So I have to find the thing.
Probably, but...
Is it in the doll?
No?
Oh, what about you?
Oh!
Eww!
Okay.
Is it in one of these dolls?
Is it in you?
Eww!
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
She's so obsessed!
Yarn did it wrinkle
this one no too tiny this one no are there other ones um i'm looking oh there one
oh i got the thingy okay like that rightward facing fox crest an emblem found in a strange room I'm jutting out at the bottom that seems like it could be inserted somewhere.
We got one.
Out of three.
Thank you.
Wait, now they're...
Wait.
Now they're...
Me?
It says die.
Oh, it says die.
It says die on them oh my gosh ew it says die die die die yabit actually yabit
what's this oh crumpled letter sorry I know this must seem like it's coming out of nowhere but what exactly is Hinako to you are you two just friends or are you more than friends I want you to tell me the truth I know this is a true thing I know this This is none of my business,
but could you keep your distance from Shu?
Yay!
I know this is none of my business, but could you keep your distance from Shu?
You know, people tend to get the wrong idea when boys and girls are aged, spend too much time together, and you don't want to cause any issues for Shu, do you?
You should really think more about how you beha.
Beha, beha, beha.
You are nothing but a fly.
All you do is get in the way.
Get lost.
others and quit buzzing around shoe all the time looks like the writer was trying to change their handwriting she's so gross she's so gross I don't think I'm trying to see if there's like any other little small things around the room Like that.
Oh, we're a man!
Not even a man.
A boy!
Oh, we're a boy!
Girl, get it together.
Oh,
just saved.
Nice.
Oh, my god.
Ah!
That was so mean.
That was so mean!
I don't know.
Oh, lock on please.
Where is she?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Ouch, I'll choke.
I don't know why I'm not very good at these ones.
I'm so bad at fighting them.
I just gotta remember they're like the things on the outside just worse.
Whoop, whoop, I have no stamina!
And I have one HP in a dream.
It's fine if I die.
Honestly.
Oh, thank you for the rain!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, gosh.
I'm so bad at them.
Well, it auto-saved, so I guess we're fine.
Let me...
Deal.
Okay.
And put this on.
Is it gonna lower?
Oh!
Helped?
Helped me?
Okay.
Alright, so we went through there.
So now I need to switch it to the white rabbit, maybe, and we can go over to there.
Oh, wait, but actually...
Oh, how do I...
Oh, yeah.
change it to the white rabbit.
Oh wait!
No!
Oh wait, I have to do it inside there.
Okay, okay, okay.
Inside the temple.
Okay, okay.
Okay, and we're gonna get ambushed again.
Oh, it's up there.
I see.
I see like it's attack.
Ah, can't you leave?
Can you leave, please?
Maybe it'll come back down and around.
Phil,
thank you so much for the farm.
Good to thank you.
We can fight it.
You think so?
I guess in this area, it's better to fight, huh?
All right.
So hold on.
I'm trying to get my bearings.
Okay, we keep the red open, which I did.
And then we do the green for the white rabbit.
Okay.
And then we go over in there.
Well, actually, if I did the bird, I could do that first.
Let's go do that instead.
Or, wait, is it coming this way?
Ooh, spooky!
So scary!
Why does it only...
Oh, walk on one foot.
It's so nasty.
Oh, I tried dodging, but I think I was stuck.
Me too.
Ouch.
Stop heading, mate.
Ouch, out, out, out, out.
Give me sanity.
Okay, good.
Okay.
I guess we'll do this last room then.
And then we'll do this one.
Alright, I'm about to be ambushed.
About to be ambushed.
Scary.
I'm scared of being ambushed!
Oh my gosh, they give me good too!
Dodge, dodge, dodge!
Please!
Oh my god.
Oh shit, oh shit.
Wait, did that get it?
No.
Wait.
Oh, it did.
It did.
Nice, nice, nice.
Holy cow.
Oh, really?
Already?
No.
So unlucky.
Okay, which means this one will wake up shortly too.
Oh, Inari-zushi!
I love Inari-zushi.
Oh, my gosh.
Traditional dish means.
of sushi rice stuffed inside seasoned deep fried tofu skins has a soft juicy texture and is said to be inari sama's favorite type of offering fully restores health stamina and current max sanity can also be used as an offering it's so yummy big fan big fan
me too i'm crying because you woke back up so soon
and it's not on the other way i guess it wouldn't be on the other side on okay we have to fight it again very nice wait uh uh
i'm checking what this does again oh greatly restores health okay because i have two of them and i've been holding off just in case what i will do is i will do these instead
There we go.
Okay.
We could run.
I could.
Actually, it's just around the corner, but I feel like I'm going to get ambushed.
Wait.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
God.
Oh, oh, my bad.
Is there something here?
Okay.
No?
Alright, let's go.
Oh, shit!
I just like...
With crazy mode on her.
All right, nice.
Oh, I went psycho mode on her.
I was like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Classroom.
Wait, this is where we were at before.
That was like 20 minutes ago in the game.
Okay, my health is all right.
My health is actually good.
Stop.
You're making me depressed.
I also remember school.
Stop it.
Stop.
Yeah, also homework and tests and...
In continuation of from last semester, I'm to be class president once again.
I hope we can make this another wonderful semester.
The role of class president holds a lot of responsibilities, but I think I'm up to the task.
Prom?
I didn't go to prom.
Even when I was young, I always wanted to be the mom or big sister whenever I played house.
I think it's because I really enjoyed looking after others.
I was just two seconds away from saying, is this Renko?
Because it's always the mean girls being hypocritical.
I believe that every single student in our class has things they excel in, as well as things they could stand to work on.
In my view, the purpose of a class president is to help others with their shortcomings.
So we can make school an enjoyable place for everyone.
You at the prom with five guys?
They let you bring in burgers?
What's a goal?
Wait, did I check back here?
I kind of want a burger now.
Stole the joke from me?
Five guys.
And fries.
Why is it called Five Guys?
Was a single...
You heard that, right?
Was a single burger invented by Five Guys?
Alright, what do we do here?
Oh.
One dad, four sons.
Surprise, this doesn't have anything written on it, you know.
I'm looking around, sorry.
In continuation from last semester, I'm to be class president once again.
I hope we can make this another wonderful semester.
The handwriting turns wild and erratic.
I love being class president because I get to look over all these lost causes.
Even when I was young, I always enjoyed comparing myself to others and fear your kids and basking in my own superiority when i pretend to care about others i can please a lot of people the losers i help the people around me and even my parents and frankly that makes me happy as well right now i'm in charge of two girls who are the definition of morons they're both so carefree and empty-headed neither of them knows the first thing about fitting in the only reason sakuko she's talking about me and sakuko
The only reason they have any friends in that class is because I'm taking care of them.
They fawn over me and tell me all the time how grateful they are.
It feels amazing.
I really truly think I was born to be class president.
Nishida Rinko.
This nasty girl.
Their true colors.
Silent Hiller is making her true colors show.
Oh.
I'm not gonna make the same mistake.
This is before.
What is this, though?
Uh-oh.
Ouch, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Wait, is there more than one?
Oh my gosh, there's two.
Okay.
An emblem found in strange room.
Oh my gosh, stop.
Stop, stop!
Stop!
Don't, don't, no, no!
Wait, I'm trapped.
I'm trying not to...
There we go.
I was trying not to be...
What's it called on her anymore?
Locked on her anymore.
Okay.
That was good.
Yeah, yeah.
Sorry.
I got so...
Okay, we're not going to get ambushed this time, please.
Thank you.
Okay.
Dinko.
Did it save?
I actually couldn't tell, but that's okay.
I love Watch Five Guy One Borgher.
What is she looking at?
It's stressing me out.
Okay.
Bombastic side eye.
Um...
We'll do that.
Alright, let's see.
Now, we got to get to the board.
So I open up a green.
Let's double check.
If it's closed.
You could leave at any time, girl!
Okay, so we open up green.
Oh, wait.
Oh, I do have to go back into that room, though.
No!
Wait.
Oh, this sucks.
I should have done the bird.
Wait, I should have done the bird first.
Oh, freaky.
Dang it.
Right now she can't.
Just do bunny and blue?
No, I can't, because then these doors will shut.
This one's right here, in the middle.
Oh, if I enter through the top.
Oh, I see, I see.
It will unleash two of those screaming baby monsters on me, but I can just run past them.
Okay.
Yeah, you're right.
Okay, you're right.
So bunny and blue.
Yeah, we just book it to the room, exactly.
My health is...
Satisfactory.
It's really this part.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot!
Let me out, please!
And you're also screaming, baby.
Okay, we got all these screaming babies going on.
Just dodge past.
And keep on, keep it on.
And open the door.
Open the door.
Oh, go in.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, this is the candy store.
Letter from Rinko to Hinako.
Hinako...
Here, you'll feel better after eating this.
Forgive what those jerks said today, and don't worry.
They'll be getting an earful from me.
You just have to be yourself, Hinako.
You can't worry about what other people say is normal.
That's their normal, not yours.
I'll always be looking out for you from your best friend, Riko.
Why did it have to turn out like this?
Why?
No!
No.
I'm going to go to Jisiru Yau.
I'm going to go to go to the world.
Aso-san!
It could have been besties!
Kutsu tea.
Oh shoot.
Maybe it's fine.
Wait.
It can also be used as an offering.
I do have two first full- two first aid kits but...
Hmm.
Could replace the chocolate.
It sells for more.
Oh, that's what I was actually going to ask.
I was going to say, does the Kudzu tea, like, well.
Let's see what else is in here, too.
Because if we get another chocolate bar.
Rinko's Secret Journal.
Why do I have to live here of all places?
Shu lives all the way on the other side of town.
This girl is, she has one train of thought, and it's Shu.
She can't think of literally anything else.
Katsu is 100?
Oh, over the chocolate, I think, was 80, right?
Meaning my dream of us walking home together will never come true.
I remember how I organized everyone from class to go to Chizuruya together after school.
We chatted as we walked, then went our separate ways home.
The walk to the store just pain was painfully short.
Still having just a few extra minutes that I could spend with Shu outside of school was all that I could have asked for.
If only a Shu wasn't such an amazing, irresistible hottie.
they could have been different i know he's just so dreamy shoo
like i get having a crush i'm not gonna fault her for you know these candies bring back memories i'm not gonna fault her for liking the guy but dang she's so obsessive with him
okay Is there anything else that I could switch out, though?
I guess everything else is kind of like...
I use, like, health items, you know?
So I guess the chocolate will replace.
Wait, how much does the divine water sell for?
How much health sanity do I have?
Oh, it's only 50?
Then we'll switch out that.
My sanity is, like, max.
So...
We'll switch out with the divine water.
Okay.
Yeah, pills don't sell for anything, but I can use them for my health.
I have been using them.
In fact, I'll take one right now.
I like reading what the...
What's it called?
The notes change to after...
I hope nothing attacks me, though, so I can actually read them, please.
Oh!
Quick!
Break!
Ow!
Jeez!
Ah!
Nice.
Oh my god.
Ow!
I'm getting combo, wombo, comboed right now.
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh, so I do need...
There's like some sort of something going on in here.
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Oh my god.
Oh, my sanity.
I mean, my stamina.
The game does not pause during cutscenes.
Yeah.
Okay, wait, did I lose him?
Or...
Oh, he's doing his echo location on me?
Holy cow.
Alright, let's do... Let's do this fast.
Bandage?
Pick that up.
As we got closer to the store, our classmates would peel off one by one as they turned to go home.
It was never just me and Shu on our own, but I didn't care.
The handwriting grows more erratic and emotional.
But of course, there was always a dirty little cockroach crawling all over Shu.
I mean, come on.
We're all walking home together.
How about having a conversation that everyone else can join in on?
Don't just go running off on your own little weird space wars world together.
I opened something and I...
Okay, I'm looking for the candy that...
Ta-da!
I feel like these are supposed to be shocking, but they end up being kind of goofy, silly.
Ah!
We found it!
Pick up, pick up!
It's kind of sad.
Alright, let's go read the last note.
Right here.
Shinako, here you'll feel better after eating this.
The handwriting becomes more erratic and emotional.
I'm such a kind person, you know.
Would someone who isn't kind give little treats with a wonderful message to their sad friend?
I am so kind.
You just have to be yourself, Shinako, because whenever I'm by your side, I realize what an amazing person I am.
Whenever I help you out, it makes me realize how kind I am.
I'll always be looking out for both you and Sakuko, because when I look after you two pitiful creatures, it makes me feel so superior.
or even pet odor from your best friend, Binkle.
She's, like, so nice.
Oh, gosh.
Wait.
There's that thing up there.
We have to be careful.
Wow.
Yeah, she's, like, such a good person.
Binko.
Wait, where do I go after this?
Maybe to that one door I couldn't go to before?
Sayonara!
Oh my gosh, us just staring at her.
Tell me the doggies are.
Oh
my god!
I'll be back.
Do-do-do-do-do-do.
Oh my god!
She's not cool!
She's kind of...
Dang!
The Tri-Scale Emblem Key obtained after bidding Bidding Farewell
Bidding Farewell Turinco.
This seems to be able to open a door somewhere and it's much bigger than the normal key as if it was made for some huge creature to use.
What was that?
Oh, I think all the things opened up.
Oh, what about...
Oh, I guess we can't go in ever.
I suppose.
Doesn't look back.
She just...
She just turned around and...
Wait.
Farewell, Rinko.
Farewell.
And safe travels to you.
Like, damn.
Oh, okay, so there's still monsters.
Okay.
I'll find a way to open the sacred door.
Is it not this?
We made it!
Hinako literally said, go to hell.
Oh.
No way.
Wait, there's a second door.
I was two seconds away from being like, well, that section wasn't so bad.
we have to do it twice
is there a journal update for dico let's see oh my bad there we go
oh my god wait what about sakuko what does she look like no she's still fine god her art is so cute
dico is always asking whether she and i are an item i tell her every time that that we're not but she never seems to buy it i heard a rumor that ninko was gossiping about me behind my back i suppose love can tear apart even the closest of friends i don't know what to do
there are times when those kind eyes that watch me through the slits of the fox mask turn frighteningly sharp frightening frighteningly sharp it's as if he is looking right through me piercing the very depths of my soul when we walk hand in hand he always stays one step ahead as if guiding me somewhere with my hand in his wait walking when are we hand holding what when did this happen i can keep my eyes cast down towards my feet when i walk when he tugs gently on my hand i know what true happiness is i don't i don't have to think about anything anymore as long as i do what he tells me i know we will be happy Hello?
Wait, who?
Not a regular YouTube viewer here saw your performance at Club Iron Mouse and loved it!
Whoa!
Thank you so much for the super chat!
Thank you!
I really appreciate you dropping by!
Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it.
Uh.
There was a dark shrine.
I think something updated.
Bizarre.
monster that looks like a bunch of celluloid dolls.
Maybe we did see this one.
Go through the door.
I don't want to do this again.
Please.
Oh, it's dark, though.
Wait, I don't like this one even more.
Who are we punishing now?
Shul, you think?
Right.
Whose room is this?
Saku-ko, okay.
I already hear somebody wandering around out there.
She loves bunnies.
She's so cute.
Saku-ko, I love you.
Where?
Oh, they're right literally as...
when you open the door.
I think?
Maybe?
That sounds like it.
I can't see from here.
We can go white bunny first, though.
Was there anything over here?
Oh, yes.
Sakuko parent teacher journal.
Just a no.
As Sakuko's mother, I want to thank you for teaching my daughter.
I wanted to apologize for what happened the other day on the field trip.
It seemed Sakuko caused a lot of trouble.
my daughter has always been that way ever since she was young as a child she always hated when the when we turned off the lights to go to bed and she avoided dark movie theaters and tunnels like the plague i mistakenly thought she had overcome her fear of the dark now that she has grown up i believe the reason her fear came back during the field trip is because she is unaccustomed to sleeping in a different environment i gave her a stern talking to for behaving so shamelessly shame shamefully at her age she has since reflected on her behavior and is sorry for how she except both her and my apologies.
That's so sad.
Wait, that's so sad.
Green.
It must be open.
Oh.
Or not.
Stop making noise in there.
You're freaking me out.
Yeah, let a girl be afraid of the dark in peace.
I'm afraid of the dark.
Sakuko, I get you.
I understand you.
No one else will.
what the oh why did i switch to that how did i do that actually
we'll be unable to reanimate oh interesting
ow wait so oh why cycle oh you're right i didn't even notice that oh it can't reanimate Oh my gosh.
Sakako is the best.
The blue flames.
Oh, yeah.
The oboe and lantern.
Is she in that box?
No.
No, no, no.
We gotta get her out of there.
It's so sad.
Ah.
Let me go sell some of these.
Yeah.
Um, Kudzu, chocolate.
180.
What's my health looking like?
Oh yeah, how much does the Enadi go for?
150.
I want to eat it though.
I want to eat it.
I still could like draw a random Omamori.
I'm trying to decide what I want to do.
If I want to increase my abilities or get a new Omamori.
Try for something else or...
Hawk is still the best.
Why does it feel so much slower than before?
Am I crazy?
Did I gaslight myself into thinking it's slower?
And then stamina.
Wait till more stamina?
You think so?
Like, keep saving up for it?
Maybe, yeah.
Okay, so this switches to rabbit.
Which opens up this.
Which I don't see anybody in there, but you never know.
Opens up that.
And the other way.
But if this is still...
if I don't know I was going to say does it switch both of them am I going to be locked in here
yeah okay
I'm just looking around okay green okay
we got a killer in here okay Whatever.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, whoops.
Why did I do that?
Come
on!
Keep stabbing!
Try to get back.
Or not.
Keep stabbing.
Oh, nice.
Yeah!
Keep stabbing.
What's happening?
Is this my locker?
Something's behind there.
I don't like it.
I think it's another...
I think it's another baby.
Baby head.
This changes red.
Tigashi?
Is this red?
Which one's red?
Oh!
Wait.
Oh, it was red and now...
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I'm like, hello.
I'm a little lost.
Stabby, stabby.
Sakuko's diary.
I hate gym class.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, there's so many pages.
And look at how erratic it's all written.
Just looking at my gym clothes makes me depressed.
They're holding a long distance race at school soon.
I know it's just an excuse for them to watch me come and last and laugh at me.
I'm so...
I am here to apologize.
day i asked about your blue archive pulls afterwards i pulled four six stars and 30 pulls in arc knights i'm sorry i
don't know actually arc knight pulls is that good okay i'm guessing it's good um yeah thanks for stealing my luck shrub that's fine i would i would much rather other uh you guys have my luck than me it's okay don't don't think about it insanely rare oh six is the highest okay got it got it six stars is three stars equivalent okay okay okay um yeah no it's okay i'd rather you uh have all i'd rather you guys have luck than than me it's fine uh i knew how lonely i would feel if everyone just left me in the dust so i asked binko if she would hang back so we could run across the finish line together and you know What?
She said yes.
I asked Hinako too.
But she said no.
She said it's because she's in a sports club and she'll get yelled at by the teacher if she doesn't try her best.
Well, I suppose that makes sense if it's true.
The handwriting suddenly turns erratic.
But I know the truth.
I know it's really because you don't want to be held back by a slowpoke like me.
I hope Hinako trips and falls and breaks all the bones in her body so she can never run again.
Are we the bad guy?
Maybe we can lure it in here.
Wait, hold on.
I'm just exploring real quick.
Maybe we can lure... Oh, wait, there.
Bandage.
No, it's okay.
It's complicated.
Yeah, it is slightly ill.
Absolutely.
Why else would we be here?
Let's try and lure it.
Oh my god.
Are you kidding me right now?
Okay, nice.
Well, we got one thing, I guess.
That was crazy!
Oh, let's see.
You.
Nice.
My sanity, though, is, like, completely gone.
But that, does that, like, regenerate over time?
I can't remember.
Who needs to be sane?
So true.
I could go back and save.
It'd be kind of a walk, though.
Come, come.
I hear you.
Come.
Oh, you're in there!
That's why!
All right, hold on.
Let me see what's going on.
Let's see the damage.
Ah, okay.
So green is open.
We could go back to the star.
Wait.
But rabbit...
I think we're on rabbit.
Yeah, we're on rabbit.
I could go save.
Yeah, it's this way.
Wait, this wasn't written here before, right?
It's the traitor.
Oh, it's written all over.
Okay.
Good, good, good, good.
And our sanity is restored?
Yeah!
Awesome.
Oh, that's not so good.
she's really yeah we should have slowed down guys we're the worst friends ever um so we go into the baby room
okay she's like really serious about this oh gosh okay she doesn't what what kind of what i wonder how we are a traitor though you know
like what did we do
is this how we get in here okay i'm kind of scared I'm quite scared.
Oh, baby.
What's over here?
Ah!
Dodge!
Oh, really?
No way!
Parried me!
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Ouch.
I should have seen that comment.
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm so screwed right now.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, we can't die yet.
We can't die yet.
Oh my gosh.
I thought I was gonna die for real, though.
Wow, I can't believe she parried me.
What's even...
There better be something good.
Okay.
I forgive you.
Oh, I could have...
Actually, I should have probably...
that instead oh well yeah i was very close whoops we're fine maybe let me go restore my sanity once again and then we will uh uh open that door monsters can't pair you just hit the wall is that what happened that's so funny if if that's it That's so silly.
I can't believe I parried the wall.
Alright, not parried.
I hit the wall.
Really?
It didn't look like I hit the wall.
Oh well, whatever.
This game is really bad for wall bonking.
Oh, okay, okay.
I didn't...
Oops.
I mean, I knew something was going to be behind there, but at the same time, it always gets me.
And then I'm bad at dealing with it.
Okay.
Okay, calm down!
I'm coming to get you, baby!
Wait, oh, you're leaving.
Wait.
Um...
Maybe we can lead it to...
Uh, oh wait, no, there is no room left.
That has the lantern.
I can't get in here either.
Dang, that kind of sucks.
But I need to get in there.
Where'd it go?
Oh, I think she is right behind me.
Ah!
Good thing it's a loop.
What's in here, anyway?
Oh.
Wait.
That's food.
Wait, what's in here?
Find Sakuko?
Huh?
That's the thing that I needed?
Maybe I have to kill it.
Maybe?
Forgot to mention yesterday, but I have received the invisible girl figure.
Whoa!
So fast!
It looks so, so good.
Thank you again for showing this figure to us, Minto.
Of course!
I'm glad you got it, Jay!
Nice.
I need to enter the green door south.
Ah, I see them, I see them, I see them!
Oh, okay.
Right now we're on red, so we need to switch it to green.
Oh, I see, okay, I forgot.
Why did I let this thing out then?
Oh my gosh, it was an absolute trap.
It wasn't- Maybe I can get it, though, to the room.
Now and kill it for good.
Well, I guess there's really no...
No, no, no.
Oh my god, such bad timing.
Rudd?
Okay.
Go silly.
Alright.
Let me sell this, though.
Because I'm a gamer?
Oh, wait.
Well, that's fine.
If this sells for good money, then why not?
Whoa!
Offering!
Yeah.
Oh.
I could do more stamina.
Health or stamina.
I almost want to do more health because I haven't increased it yet.
Oh, stam is the way.
If you have...
If you have so much stamina, you can just dodge for days, which is pretty nice.
So, I think, yeah, stamina.
We'll go stamina.
Yippee!
And, honestly, I mean, I could just offer, like, this.
And then get health, too, if I really wanted it.
Wait, I have no more emma?
Okay.
Oh my gosh, you're right.
No!
Oh, no!
Okay, we'll find another one.
Someday.
Whoops, whoops.
Uh.
Alright, now we switch this up.
Okay.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Do you see that down there?
Oh my gosh.
You see that!
That person down there in the hall!
That's freaky.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Oh, what about the blue...
Okay, whatever.
Just a box.
We'll have to change it back to blue somehow.
I don't want to go that way.
Oh.
Well, it doesn't matter what I want.
Does not matter what I want.
Come on.
Oh
shoot, dang it.
Ah, I tried to dodge.
Bad at it.
Okay, cool.
Oh my goodness.
Okay, okay.
All right, let's, I guess we'll go that way then.
I hear like chains.
Jingling.
Oh, maybe these.
I know these are...
I really...
I know these areas are like...
Puzzly.
They're supposed to be like a puzzle, you know.
But I just don't...
like them.
I'm just not a big fan.
I wish more puzzle-less combat.
what's in there?
No one likes this part?
Okay, I'm glad it's not just me, then.
Okay.
You liked this part?
It's fine if you do.
It's just, I don't like it.
Musagi.
What's wrong?
What's in there?
Oh, there's that guy over there.
That's not what I was hearing though, is it?
There's no way.
Is it?
I don't think so.
Yeah, the blue lantern definitely helps a lot.
Yeah.
I'm scared to go in here.
Oh, come on.
Where did you come from?
I don't even read, I don't even hear what she said.
Something about a freak liking bunnies?
What's wrong with liking bunnies?
Hey, Mr. Raba, guess what?
I made my first ever friend today.
Her name is Shimizu Hinako.
But Mr. Raba, she's my first ever real-life human friend, so I'm a little scared.
What if she throws me away and forgets me?
not happening.
When I told my new bestest friend Hineko this, she said she never ever, ever abandoned me.
Not ever.
She promised me.
But you know what, Mr. Rabbit?
His handwriting suddenly turns erratic.
Uh-oh.
What if Hineko breaks her promise?
What if she betrays me?
What if she's lying?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, I don't want to think about that.
Hineko said she wouldn't ever leave me.
She promised.
I have to believe her because that's what friends do, right?
They believe each other.
Hineko, if you betray me, you'll pay.
I'll make you pay Got it!
Hold on, I'm gonna take a...
A throat...
What's it called?
Cough drop.
Got...
Um, well...
We need that thing to come in here.
Where did it go?
It took too long.
Wait, no, I need you in here!
I need to in here before I open that and that guy ambushes me.
Oh, here we are.
Please?
Down the long hallway goes.
Come, come, come.
Come, come.
Oh, yeah.
Ouch!
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I meant to do.
Ah, my sanity!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, my sanity!
Oh, once sanity goes down, then your health starts going down.
That's right.
Wait, what was that?
There's like a loud bang.
Okay.
Also, you can't focus.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It does eventually...
It's very slow, but it does Build back up.
Check in here again in case I...
I guess I...
I guess it was nothing.
It only recovers to about that much.
Yikes!
Okay.
Well, I haven't been, like, keeping...
Do I have anything for Sanity?
I think I have, like, just...
Just the Inazushi.
I don't want to use it on.
I'm understanding why sanity is good.
Oh, the pills do?
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Let's...
Oh, the one thing I hate about these areas is they don't have very many save points.
You know?
They don't have very many save points.
So if I die here, I have to redo everything.
Yeah, you get a save point and you backtrack for it, pretty much.
Oh, but this is pretty forgiving.
Because once I switch this, I can just, I can just, okay.
Maybe I can lead him.
And it's only two, right?
Yeah, they're not like, uh, okay.
Does he walk all the way down?
the hall?
Hello?
You want to come in here?
No?
All right.
Yeah, I remember he is blind.
Oh, wait.
He's gonna go in there first.
Oh, he goes in there?
Wait, I thought he went down the hall.
Oh, that sucks.
Stealth mission.
I'm just gonna go for it.
Because I'm scared.
Oh, save point.
Okay.
Okay, good.
Yeah, I did see something in that room.
I don't know if he'll come in here.
Let's see what else is in here.
Let's check around before I go back in.
dream is that what it says
Sakuko's diary my family has served as caretaker of sennenesugi shrine for generations but for the past few decades the shrine's popularity has been on the deep on the decline when it came time for my dad to become the head priest he declined the role and got a regular office job instead oh wow she wanted to be a miiko oh that's right i think i remember her saying that mom and dad are always saying negative things about the shrine that head priests are obsolete even my grandfather says that the tradition of upkeeping sennen sugi shrine will die with his generation no is it because inadi shrine became so popular oh inadi it became so popular in the in the village in the town oh my gosh look at the cute little rabbit on her drawing paper so cute i help out as a miko at the shrine whenever an event's held i love how dignified the rituals are and the way they make me feel like my soul is being cleansed.
I'd like to be more than just a helper at the shrine.
I think I'd like to become head priest one day.
Oh,
there's a baby in there.
Let's see what this guy does.
Does he loop?
He doesn't even loop.
Kudzu.
Ah, no!
I have too many things.
what's my uh shoot guys we might have to wait what do i drop oh my gosh
go offer some stuff yeah but like what
i guess i could offer the higashi
inari zushi has to go okay
I think also you're right because
blow away
I don't want to deal with the baby I don't want to deal with the baby Alright and then we can sell this too Is there anything else around here?
8.10 We're at 8.10 Oh yeah that's right I don't have the Emma What if I drop?
I have money.
I want to spend it.
Oh, oops, my bad.
I think I've done that twice now.
Gotcha!
Okay.
I have to just deal with the baby.
And then I can leave.
Dodge for good luck.
We'll let this guy leave again.
all the way down the other hallway, you know?
Be really nice of him.
Hello?
There we go.
Close up.
Come in, please!
Come in, please, so I can handle you.
Oh, actually?
You don't see anything.
Sheet a fine paper.
Two must face each other as one to pray for mutual prosperity.
Those who do not shall...
Wait, those who do shall lift their heads to level...
I can't read!
To level height as if they were reflections in a mirror as custom dictates.
With the shading of light shall you condemn the past to the dark.
Okay, what?
So it's another puzzle, but like...
Oh, wait, do I have to...
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, let me read it again.
Two must face each other as one to pray for mutual prosperity.
Those who do shall lift their head to level height.
As if...
Okay.
Good luck with this one.
I'm kind of just wondering what the end goal is though.
So I have to make all of these cages.
Oh, there's this part too.
The same height.
Oh, but that doesn't.
Okay.
Ah, okay.
The same height.
Maybe.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Is that not enough?
Aren't those the only ones that are moving?
What did I miss?
I got it?
Oh, I did it.
But then nothing happened.
Oh, there are items inside?
Oh, I see!
Oh, okay, hold on.
Just looking at what each one has.
Restraint Lampshade.
Lampshade found near Sakako's cell.
The design resembles something tangling.
And then...
Talon Lampshade.
The lampshade found near Sakako's cell.
The design resembles sharp talons.
Okay.
Are we turning off the light?
I had a feeling that we...
I thought like maybe the turning of those would like turn off the light.
No, this is so messed up!
This is so messed up.
I mean, she's got a big lamp in there, though.
Poor babies.
Hina, Hina, Hina, help me.
Help me, help me.
Don't go.
Pretty messed up.
Obtained after bidding farewell to Sakuko.
Seems to be able to open a door somewhere, okay.
I would like to save the game.
I don't want to watch that again.
I didn't like that.
Or it was just 500 yen.
I didn't Oh, her voice acting was like I can't tell if they're in if it's in the hallway or what Her voice acting was too good though I didn't like it
Oh Well wait, I give it to the This guy over here That's right I think honestly Like They really were good at making you dislike Rinko.
We had no reason to dislike Sakuko, you know?
Hers was totally... It felt so much worse because she felt so innocent, you know?
What have you been the last time?
What?
What the heck is this?
Oh, laser gun!
Jisu!
Thanks for the 200 yen.
You're a short five!
I'm just kidding.
Choose possessions, okay?
Can I go through here?
I guess not.
Space Wars!
What is this?
Aww.
Yeah,
he sounds in pain.
Carried not any memory of what has come to pass beyond this point.
Lay all bare upon the pedestal first.
The door shall not open to those who harbor regrets in their hearts.
Was there something that I already have?
Oh yeah, let's see the portrait in...
Wait, what's this?
Memories.
Oh, okay.
Info?
Characters, there we go.
Sakuko.
Oh, poor baby!
I think Sakako may have read one too many of those bizarre comics.
Lately, she'll be laughing all happily one moment and turn deadly serious and spout off some weird nonsense the next.
Apparently, she's acting like that because she thinks it's cool.
But it kind of creeped me out the first few times she did it.
I hope she gets over this weird supernatural phase of hers.
She's in middle school!
This is what all middle schoolers do.
She's Chuni Byo.
It's fine.
Oh, I didn't finish reading these, too.
I remember Dinko folding up origami all the time.
I don't know what was on them, but I saw her writing down things during class and folding paper into foxes on multiple occasions.
She keeps writing her complaints on pieces of paper, but instead of burning them, she just decides to throw them in the void and let them accumulate.
I think that maybe one day all of those grievances will pile up and suffocate her.
Or burn her alive.
a world that's not a playground like elementary school but not as mature as high school middle school to me it was like the stage between a tadpole and a frog i guess you could say it's a period of grotesque transformations up until elementary school shu and i would have water fights and we wouldn't mind if our underwear showed once we entered middle school though while we might not have paid any mind to things like that others around us did it felt like our world changed in a snap
Sakuko wasn't trying to freak you out.
No, Hidako!
Boys and girls used to think of one another as mortal enemy as always bickering and fighting each other.
But now it suddenly turned into such a weird dynamic where we have to treat each other in a completely different way.
It's fine for people who want to do that because the people around them are doing the same.
But for someone like me who really couldn't care less about what people think, that's not the case.
Sorry.
Shu and I decided that this place...
The Chizuru General Store.
Shu and I decided that this place was the Space Army HQ when we played Space Wars.
When it wasn't just us playing, we would gather here to have mission briefings while eating candy.
Okay.
Oh, save point.
Why are you doing all the way back here in the corner?
Fine shoes prize possession.
You guys, I think I might actually call it here today.
thing um because i feel like the last or rather rinko and sakoko took so long i don't know how long shoe will take so yeah i think we'll end it here and then we will pick it up next week
so but i streamed for way longer than i thought i I thought I would be coughing so much too, but I think once I started talking, the coughing went away from me.
So I'm glad for that.
Yay!
So thank you guys for hanging out with me again today.
I'm starting to get...
Wait, let's hear what Shu says for this too.
The question we have right now, are we the baddies?
I'm really upset about Sakuko, I'm not gonna lie.
So we don't like Shu in that way.
You know, we don't romantically like Shu.
Rinko is upset at us because she thinks that we let him on and she likes him so much.
but she's upset that he likes us probably some girl asked me to give you this 500 yen to you oh my gosh from baffo caro thank you so much for the 500 yen i'm gonna go buy a pudding with that yeah i bozo and i bozo hi bozo i bozo and then with sakuko though She,
what?
Hinako just thought she was a little weird?
Thanks for the fun stream.
Looking forward to the lyric video tomorrow.
Yeah, thanks, Take Me.
I do have a lyric video coming out of my original song.
It's just the same performance from me during my 3D debut, my birthday live, but with lyrics.
So, yeah.
Thank you for the stream today, Minto.
I helped me get through cleaning my house today.
Now it's Extra Clean for Future Ghost Made Hauntings.
Yeah, good job.
I hear and don't know what's going on, but here's $5.
Star creator, thank you!
Thanks for dropping by.
Hmm.
Which doesn't make sense since Hinako plays space wars.
Plays space wars.
Wait, what do you mean?
Feels like less punishing your friends and more like letting them go entirely.
Yeah.
It's very weird so far.
I'll keep, I'll keep, I'll sleep on it and see how I feel.
there is more story in new game plus i have oh my goodness i'm so sorry i have heard that um you have to play this game multiple times to get the true ending which i would like to do but at the same time going through some of these things again i think if i'm less scared like if i am more used to it like i am now i would probably be a little bit faster but Um Yeah We'll see You get to keep your stats and items Huge
But yeah It could be a bit of a grind That's the only thing I am Kind of like About
Oh gosh I can't stop yawning Okay this is a good place to end then Since I can't stop yawning All of a sudden Remember hanging out with me, I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you so, so much.
Yeah, I really appreciate it.
And I hope you guys have a great day, have a great night.
And I will see you when I see you next.
Eat de lasai.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye-bye.
See you later.
Bye-bye.